. Hallo Stuttgart! Hey guys! Ihr seid da! Dankeschön! Vielen Dank! Meine Damen und Herren, er ist im Haus, hier Stefan Tietze! Er ist da! Er ist da! Und natürlich ist mit dabei, Florentin Will! Dankeschön! Danke! Noch ist nichts passiert. Ihr seid so gütig! Dankeschön! vielen Dank. Und Laura ist da! Und Thomas! Und Markus! Na, weniger als Laura. Und Anna, Ruhe einfach, niemand. Anna, nobody cares, Applaus ist vorbei. Das ist das weirdeste Telegram-Rules. Das ist ein Ausrufezeichen. Einer kriegt immer das Ausrufezeichen, weil einer ist immer zu viel da und man zählt die Buchstaben und dann bleiben wir als Satzzeichen über. Ich war immer Semikolon. Du, ich kann leider nicht zur Probe kommen, dann machst du das Ausrufezeichen. Das passt schon, das ist kein Problem. Immer so New York Mets Fragezeichen? Sternchen"? Wir hatten gesagt Ausrufezeichen.
Machen Sternchen, Semikolon?
Ja, halt ruhig die ganze Show hoch, finde ich ganz gut.
Du bist wie so ein Questgeber in World of Warcraft mit dem Ausrufezeichen so die ganze Zeit.
Ich glaube, da sprechen dich sehr interessante Leute an, wenn du diese Ausrufezeichen über dem Kopf hast den ganzen Abend.
Angenommen, wir würden jetzt zu dir hingehen, was hättest du für eine Quest für uns heute Abend?
Drei Komplimente. Ich geb dir eineinhalb. Schöner Pulli.
Ja, und ich bezahle ich bei Ebay dafür, dass jemand diese Quest macht.
Das muss reichen, das muss reichen. Stuttgart, ihr seid das erste Publikum der dritten Podcast-Ufo-Live-Tour. Ja! Ja! Ja! Die drei! Ja, ja. Naja, die dritte Tour. Ist es die dritte? Es ist die dritte. Die erste waren zwei Auftritte. Ich habe heute extra nochmal durchgezählt und es sind tatsächlich drei, ihr seid die allerersten, also strengt euch verdammt nochmal an. Ja. Die dritte muss okay werden eigentlich, sehr gut, sehr gut. Die Leute sind hyped. Die Telegram-Gruppe hat sich bewährt. Wunderbar, schön, dass ihr da seid. Herzlich willkommen in diesem fantastischen Hallen, in denen schon so viel passiert, ist eine ehemalige Zeppelin-Bauhalle. Oh mein Gott, wirklich? Ja, habe ich mir sagen lassen. Oh, ich liebe ja Zeppeline. Hier wurden zweihundert Zeppeline gebaut, kein einziger ist jemals abgehoben, schade. Dafür sind wir heute da, wir werden heute stellvertretend abnehmen.
Ich glaube, Zeppeline sind nicht zum Abheben gedacht einfach, die sind einfach nur so cool, die sind ja cool, für Werbung sind die auch cool. Ich glaube auch und vor allem irgendwie, ich glaube, es gab so einen Punkt, ab dem die Zeppelin-Produktion weniger Geld eingebracht hat als die Hüpfburg-Produktion.
Und man sich dachte, Leute, eins plus eins, wir machen Hüpfburgen draus. Ja, wir haben grob schon eine Hüpfburg gebaut. Das stimmt schon. Es gibt ja diesen großen Streit, das eine ist Zeppelin, das andere ist, habe ich vergessen, Flugzeug vielleicht? Nee, das ist sowas ähnliches. Das eine ist halt mit Heliumartigem Gedöns gefüllt und das andere hat das nur am Rand. So, das eine heisst Zeppelin, das andere heisst... Blip! Blip, okay, alles klar. Gut. Gut, jemand ruft ein Wort rein, was man nicht versteht, aber so heisst es ja wahrscheinlich. Und bei das eine fliegt, das andere fährt. Wir wurden auch wieder korrigiert übrigens, weil wir über Ballonfahrer gesprochen haben schon wieder.
Wir haben Pilot, haben wir den genannt.
Wir sind natürlich Ballonfahrer, wo ich mich frage, das Coolste an eurem Job ist, dass ihr euch Pilot nennen könntet.
Und sie nennen sich Fahrer, Ballonfahrer.
Aber die haben auch eine der härtesten Lobbys der Welt, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
Also wir haben schon gegen viele Personengruppen gehetzt, keiner hat sich so hart drückgemeldet wie die Ballonfahrer, sorry. Sehr hart, aber ein weicher Kern oder einfach nur Luft, kein Kern. Ja, dünne Haut, kein Kern. Warmer, dünne Haut, warmer Kern, wohlig warmer Kern. Ja, genau. Ich glaube, wir haben das mal wieder gesagt, wir machen mal eine Folge aus Spaß im Heissluftballon, ich glaube, mich kriegen da keine zehn Pferde rein. Auch ein veraltetes Sprichwort. Wann sind zehn Pferde nochmal ein Problem? Heute sagt man, heute kriegen mich keine fünf Elektroroller rein, damit die Millennials auch fein mitleiten. Nee, tatsächlich, weil du hast halt diese beissende Flamme und das Einzige, was dich von dem Kilometer weit entfernten Boden weg abhält, ist halt diese dünne Papierschicht. Du du hast aber auch dir überlegt, eine Flamme reinzubauen. Ja. Finde ich schwierig. Ja, es stimmt schon. Vor allem ist es verboten, Marshmallows mitzubringen? Ist es schlechter Geschmack? Stockbrot. Darf man das? Stockbrot plötzlich. Oder ist es dann ungern gesehen? Was machen Sie da? Hey! Während die anderen beiden Passagiere gerade ihren Hochzeitsantrag machen und man nebenbei so die Marschle, macht mal weiter, macht weiter, lasst euch nicht von mir ablenken. Lasst euch nicht von mir stören, aber herzlichen Glückwunsch. Hat er schon ja gesagt? Nein, oh! Und dann bricht er so ein Handgemenge und dabei kommt der Stock leider in den Ballon rein. Ah, ich glaube, daran sind auch sehr viele Zeppelins kaputtgegangen tatsächlich. Zeppelins, auch schon wieder so eine Frage. Ach, heisst es Zeppelins. Ich we es nicht gesagt, aber angenommen, jetzt Flugzeuge fliegen, Zeppeline fahren, wie sieht es mit Hüpfburgen aus, was machen die? Stehen. Die stehen einfach nur rum. Das ist eigentlich gerade unsere, unser Verteidigungsring sind Hüpfburgen eigentlich. Im Grunde, wenn wir angegriffen werden, wir müssen uns in Hüpfburgen zurückziehen. Es gibt nicht mehr so viele Burgen. Warum Burgen eigentlich, warum sind es nicht Hüpfpaläste oder Hüpfräume zum Beispiel?
Ja, da hat der Adel natürlich noch viel Einfluss in der deutschen Gesellschaft. Sollte man da mal kritisch hinterfragen? Nein. Oder doch? Ich weiß es nicht. Der Adler hat aber generell noch zu viel Einfluss, finde ich. Wir mussten für die zweite Staffel der Serie drehen in einem Waldgebiet, und dieses Waldgebiet hat einem Grafen gehört.
Und da hat man vorher wie bei Django Unchained so ein Briefing bekommen, wie man den anzusprechen hat. Man soll bitte den der Grafen auch nennen. Und das ganze Team hat es halt vergessen oder halt nicht ernst genommen, primär nicht ernst genommen, hat ihn halt nicht der Graf genannt, woraufhin wir, glaube ich, das Grundstück nicht bedrehen durften, weil er sauer war. Es hat schon ein bisschen was Erbärmliches, wenn man so, er hätte gern, dass ihn einen Graf nennt. Also kommt schon, Leute, bitte. Er hat eins seiner drei Schlösser letztes Jahr verloren und deswegen wäre es ganz nett, wenn er... An wen hat er das verloren eigentlich? Gegen wen hat der Graf noch Krieg geführt? Einen Schwarzen Ritter. Oder die Stadt Göttingen oder so. Man weiss es nicht genau. Ich bin ja tatsächlich mit einem Grafen zur Schule gegangen. Und ich habe mich nicht gut mit dem vertragen. Ich weiß auch nicht warum. Jetzt bist du verbannt worden. Meine französischen Wurzeln. Ich habe aber immer nur gehört, dass wenn der Kindergeburtstag gefeiert hat, dann wurde halt auf seiner fucking Burg gefeiert, wo halt auch Ritterrüstungen rumstanden und ein Folterkeller irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht genau, was davon Legende war und was war, aber ich fand das immer total faszinierend, aber ich habe es nie geschafft, den anzufreunden. Das ist nicht dein primäres Ziel, du hast ja doch Pfeil und Bogen gebaut, du bist doch in den Wald gezogen und hast den Pfeil und Bogen gebaut, warum befreundet man sich dann nicht zumindest mit dem Typen, der Rütterrüstung, wo sich zu Hause rumstehen hat?
Ich war eine Gefahr, ich war eine Gefahr für seinen Wild, so. Ich war der einzige Wildjäger in der Gegend. Ich habe scharf geschossen. Der Waldläufer Florentin. Er nähert sich. Nee, das war Gandalf, ne? Du bist schon wieder im falschen Franchise. Das ist immer so, wir haben dann immer Herr der Ringe gespielt als Jugendliche, und dann waren immer so vier Freunde,
von denen waren drei Herr der Ringe-Fans, und dann war es so einfach, ich bin Faramir, der Waldläufer,
ich bin Boromir, der Marschall von Gondor, ich bin Legolas, der Prinz des Elbenwaldes.
Ja, hei, ich bin Stefan und ich komme als Darth Vader.
Genau, und der vierte so, ja, ich habe nur den ersten Teil halb gesehen, ich bin, keine Ahnung, Ganda, Gummling, ich bin Dumbledore, der halt immer so dabei war einfach so, weil leider seine Freunde sind alle Herr der Ringe-Fans, aber er war keiner. Der Trick ist, als schwarze Kapuzengestall zu kommen, da bist du in den meisten Franchises gut aufgehoben. Bei Star Wars kommst du als Java durch, bei Herr der Ringe kommst du als
Nazgul durch, bei Harry Potter als Dementor, so es geht einfach immer weiter. Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Ich glaube wirklich, so bei den Schlümpfen bist du dein Gagamel, irgendwie so du kommst überall...
Es gibt überall die weirde, ja, die weirde Puzzengestalt. Du warst noch nicht auf allzu viele Schlumpfpartys,
merke ich aus deiner Reaktion. Nee, ich bin es gleich ein bisschen über Schlumpfpartys. Ja? Ja.
Wir hatten tatsächlich Schlumpfpartys mit dieser Musik, was normale Popmusik einfach vier Oktaven höher war. Wie Chipmunks. Wie die Chipmunks. Und dann hat man diese blauen Marwam-Kracher gegessen. Hat man sich laut angemalt? Das war, nee, nee, das nicht. Bluefacing? Das war verboten mittlerweile, glaube ich. Nee, Copyright-Probleme mit der Blue Man Group, die sind knallhart, die kommen vorbei und treten nicht kaputt.
Die können sehr, sehr hart treten, die machen ja immer so Trommelmusik und dann Trommel. Was sind denn die Bedingungen, was muss man mitbringen, die Qualitätskriterien, um bei der Blue Man Group aufgenommen zu werden?
Ich weiß nicht. Rhythmusgefühl, klar. Ja, und du darfst vor allem keine Haare haben. Ich glaube, du darfst keine Haare haben, das ist glaube ich so das Allerwichtigste.
Und den Willen, sich halt lange Zeit anzumalen, oder? Das stimmt schon eigentlich, ja. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die da so eine Strip-Nummer machen, wo die sich komplett ausziehen und man denkt, wie blau ist er? Also bis wie weit ist er gegangen? Weil das wäre eine Strip-Show, die mich interessieren würde. Bis jetzt, Strip-Shows, ich habe nicht viel Erfahrung gemacht, vielleicht bin ich da nicht drin, vielleicht sind da Fans im Publikum, aber bis jetzt irgendwie eher uninteressant, aber einen Blue Man strippen
würde ich mir anschauen. Ja, bis wohin habt ihr euch angemalt? Ja, das ist immer so meine erste Frage, wenn ich so Bodypaint-Sachen sehe, so auf Instagram kommt einem das dann so und man denkt sich, wie weit ist es wirklich gegangen? Ich finde das Shirt schon spannend, weil Menschen sind ja blasser. Also ich habe einen sehr blassen Oberkörper und noch, weil ich selten auch shirtless durch durch die Sonne laufe. Und deswegen, weiss ich nicht, sind die weniger, sind die hellblauer da, wo das Shirt ist? Und dann, weil, man kennt das ja, die Genitalgegend ist dann noch weisser, weil man noch seltener ohne Badehose rumläuft als ohne Shirt. Das heißt, ist das dann noch weniger dunkelblau oder sind die da dann nicht mehr angemalt? Du meinst, dass wir verschiedene Farben brauchen, um das wieder auszugleichen? Different Shades of Blue. Es gibt bestimmt eine Fanfiction von Blue Man Group für die Shades of Blue. Ich finde das so gut, wenn die so mit diesen ganzen Diversity-Diskussionen einfach mal jemanden einbauen, der rot ist zum Beispiel. Ja. Oder grün. Das stimmt schon. Die sind super, die sind nicht diverse, die Blue Man Group.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Ich weiss nicht, ob es da schon Skanale gab, aber so haben auch, glaube ich, die Power Rangers
angefangen, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, jetzt brauchen wir noch einen roten, noch einen schwarzen.
Und dann irgendwie, mittlerweile, glaube ich, sind diese 26 verschiedene Power Rangers,
komplette, und dann so der eine Typ, ja wie, Ultraviolett, was soll das, und dann so,
mein Gott, wir haben Briefe bekommen, scheiss drauf, zieh die Maske an.
Man kann mich nicht sehen, man kann mich nicht sehen, man kann die Farbe Ultraviolett nicht
Vielen Dank. Der eine Typ, ja wie, ultraviolett, was soll das? Und dann so, mein Gott, wir haben Briefe bekommen, scheiß drauf, zieh die Maske an. Man kann mich nicht sehen. Man kann mich nicht sehen, man kann die Farbe ultraviolett nicht sehen. Ich weiß, ich weiß, wir haben da diese Wissenschaftler, die sind so klug, die schicken uns nach jeder Folge Mails, wie das mit Farben funktioniert. Das stimmt. Wir kriegen auch mal viele Mails, wo uns penibel erklärt wird, wie dumm wir sind. Von euch, euch, vielen Dank dafür. Vielen Dank. Man hat sonst keine Chance. Ja, ich sehe da schon eine nickend, ja, ja. Man hat sonst keine Chance, sich zu bedanken. Ich kann sie gerne noch mal erklären. Ja, das ist auch immer so ein bisschen der Unterschied zwischen jemandem etwas beibringen oder jemandem bis ins Detail erklären, was er noch nicht weiß. Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Dinge, die zwei sehr unterschiedliche Dinge. Man sagt einfach, was du nicht verstanden hast, ist, du hast nicht verstanden, wie das und das funktioniert. Okay, gut, dann weiss ich das jetzt auch. Aber wie gehst du darauf ein? Frage eins, Frage zwei, versuchst du das, weil ich bin manchmal nicht überzeugt von der Antwort, die ich da bekomme, auch wenn es dann irgendwie Doktor der Physik ist, zum Beispiel, weil ich zum Beispiel neulich habe ich eine interessante Mail bekommen zum Thema Zeitreisen, so, und dann war, weil meine Theorie ist, Zeitreisen sind nicht möglich, weil man Dinge aus dem Nichts erschaffen kann. Beispiel. So, der Stefan am Ende der Show reist zurück und gibt mir, dem Stefan der jetzigen Show, eine Wasserflasche. Die bekomme ich ja nur, weil der Stefan aus der Zukunft zurückreist und mir die gibt. Aber diese Flasche wurde dann per Definition nie abgefüllt oder ist nie entstanden, dieses Glas wurde nie geblasen, ich weiß nicht, wie Glas entsteht, aber ich verstehe nicht, wie Glas funktioniert, aber ich verstehe, wie Zeitreisen funktionieren. Viele Science-Fiction-Autoren scheitern am Glasbläser, das ist immer so ein bisschen das Problem. Scheiße! Ach ja, das sind andere Probleme. Aber versteht ihr das Problem, dieses Glas wurde dann nie gemacht, weil ich habe das ja geschlossener Kreis. Ja, aber du hast es irgendwo auch hergenommen. Der Weg dieser Flasche. Stefan hat es ja von irgendwo genommen. Ja, aber dann wurde ja die Zeitachse verändert. Gut, ich widerspreche dir gar nicht. Zeitreisen sind nicht möglich, das ist korrekt. Und da hast du eine Nachricht bekommen aus dem Jahre 2070 und gesagt, tja, Jokes on you. Ja, und du verdammt nochmal. Dammit. Er hatte recht. Ne, wir kriegen sehr viele Nachrichten, in denen uns aufgezeigt wird, wie dumm wir sind. Und ich glaube, irgendwann werde ich mir die mal veröffentlichen, so als Buchband,
mal wirklich so einfach, weil es gibt ja viele Leute, die ihre Memoiren schreiben und Biografien,
die ja immer sehr positiv sind, so das habe ich gemacht, den habe ich gerettet,
dem habe ich irgendwie mal 50 Cent gegeben und so eine lange Liste. Dumme Sachen, die ich im Podcast gemacht habe, Band eins.
Und ich will wirklich so eine negativen Memoiren-Biografie machen,
wo einfach so alle dummen Sachen, so wirklich so ein Kopfschüttler irgendwie, die SZ titelt, Kopfschüttler von der ersten Seite an. Aber wirklich so, wo man sich denkt, mein Gott, was für ein Vollidiot und einfach so eine Dokumentation, was man nicht weiss. Ich finde, das ist sehr erfrischend. Und wie dick ist das Buch? Sehr, sehr dick, tatsächlich sehr, sehr dick. Ich stehe ja jeden Morgen auf und überlege mir so, was weiss ich noch nicht? So, wo muss ich noch dran arbeiten, was sind so Lücken, die ich noch habe und dann gehe ich durch den Tag und versuche das langsam aufzufüllen. Das Problem ist bei Amazon, dass die Bücher dicke nicht angegeben ist. Hast du die Erfahrung gemacht? Ja, habe ich gemacht. Ich habe Bücher bestellt, ich war nicht spannend, war und dann kamen halt wirklich ungelungen so gebundene Bücher mit dieser Dicke raus, dann zu Hause an. Jast du für unsere Hörer am Apparat das beschreiben? Nee. Ich wüsste nicht, mir fehlen keine Worte, fallen mir ein, um diese Dicke zu beschreiben. Vor allem, du könntest das locker auch mit dem Zeigefinger machen, warum machst du das mit dem Mittelfinger? Guck mal, du sparst Energie. Nein, das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaubest, der Zeigefinger anzuheben ist weniger Energie aufwendig als das? Mittelfinger ist schwerer, der braucht mehr Energie. Das sind die kleinen Sachen im Alltag, wo du Energie spart. Weißt du, wie wir uns sehr viel Energie hätten sparen können, wenn wir diesen Scheiss gelassen hätten? Aber das stimmt. Und tatsächlich, das ist ein Problem, aber stattdessen sieht man häufig, wie gross das Buch ist im Vergleich zu einem Menschen. Das kennt man, wenn man halt so die Bilder durchklickt, landet man irgendwann bei so einem Schildern so ein Mensch, wenn man das aus Dinosaurierbüchern kennt, um herauszufinden, wie gross Dinosaurier sind, ist ja unten immer so eine Frau abgebildet, so als for scale. Und dann ist es auch irgendwie ein Buch und daneben ist so eine Frau-Silhouette, die einem dann sagt, wie grosses Buch ist. Die sich versucht gross zu machen. Ja, oder besonders clever auch ein Buch liest oder so. Aber das ist ein Problem, weil das ist mir egal, ehrlich gesagt, wie gross das Buch im Wald in so einer Frau ist. Ich würde gerne wissen, das ist halt... So kannst du nicht in der Bahn, kannst du mit so einem Schinken kommen. Nein, ich will wissen, wie dick ist es im Vergleich zu dem dicksten Buch, das ich jemals gelesen habe. Wenn es dünner ist, lese ich es, wenn es dicker ist als irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Harry Potter Teil sechs oder so, keine Chance. Ich habe das einmal für Hermine gemacht, seitdem nie wieder, nie fucking wieder. Ich mache es nicht mehr, ich lasse mich nicht darauf ein, er macht kleinere Schrift, es lohnt sich nicht, es lohnt sich nicht. Die grösste Enttäuschung für mich, dass Silmarillion, J.R.R. Tolkien, Herr der Ringe Hintergrundgeschichte, ist es einfach nur eine Aufzählung von Namen. Das hat mich so wütend gemacht, ich war wirklich wütend auf dem Buch, war wirklich einfach wütend. Aber von daher vielleicht hat es funktioniert. Wann warst du wütend, wann setzt du die Wut ein? Also hast du es interessiert gelesen, monatelang, und war es dann wütend, oder warst du ab Name 3 wütend? Nee, ich bin auf Seite 12 gelesen und dachte mir, wann kommt Legolas, wann kommt Legolas, und dann war es das. Und dann kam Legolas. Bei Elle, ja das stimmt. Ja, das, so weit habe ich nicht gelesen. Die besten Sachen kommen ja immer bei Elle, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Legolas, Lego, Liebe. Ah, sehr schön, ich habe gehört, dass in der Telegram-Gruppe das so ein bisschen auch als Single-Börse umfunktioniert wird. Zwangsverkuppelung, also falls ihr noch auf der Suche seid, meldet euch da an.
Ich glaube, es gibt noch ein bisschen was. Ich glaube, es ist noch nicht ganz leer.
Es ist noch nicht leer gedatet, die Gruppe, es ist noch ein bisschen was übrig.
Ja.
Kann man noch was zusammenkratzen.
Wer ist denn hier aus der Gruppe da und ist Single?
Ach guck mal, alle.
Alle, die aus der Gruppe da sind, sind auch Single. Also hat es noch nicht ganz funktioniert.
Verdammt. Muss man sagen. muss man sagen. Was ist das? Das ist immer so, das ist unser erstes unangenehmes Date. Ja, das stimmt. Aber auch ein sehr souveränes Handschütteln einfach so ein bisschen. Ja, vor allem beim Date sollte man dann vielleicht nicht den vor ihm machen. Auch schwierig. Das ist immer das Unangenehmste, gerade so bei Stand-Up-Comedians, die dann immer so Crowdwork machen und dann so, ah, bist du mit ihm da und seid ihr zusammen und beide so, weiss nicht mehr.
Warum geht man zu einer Comedy-Show beim ersten Date und setzt sich in der ersten Reihe, um dann geroasted zu werden?
Wie wir in New York, wo wir die seit dummen Deutschen, der eine mit der Jogginghose, ich sag jetzt nicht wer, der eine mit der Jogginghose und den Birkenstockschuhen, da saß, das ist wie so eine Zielscheibe, du hast dir eine Kleider gewordene Zielscheibe angezogen. Ja, mach Witze. Und ich saß daneben und musste immer lachen. Und irgendwann ist das auch unangenehm, aber man muss immer lachen, weil ich ja auch selbst der selbstironische Deutsche sein. Ja, es stimmt schon, es stimmt schon. Ich finde, man sollte da all hingehen, wenn man fragt, seid ihr zusammen, einfach sagen, wir sind seit sieben Jahren verheiratet, beim ersten Date, einfach komplett all hingehen. Ich glaube, das ist besser als... Und sie macht da nicht mit und sagt, das stimmt doch gar nicht, sondern erstes Date. Hast du die Papiere nicht bekommen? Erster Streit, Streits verbinden, habe ich immer gelesen. Wie lässt sich streiten? Ich habe gehört, Parallelsstreiten sind besser. Was für eine Skala. FIFA oder so. FIFA. Einfach besser. Dann einfach, irgendwas ist da keine Ahnung. Bist du gut in FIFA? Extrem schlecht. Das könnte so ein Hidden Talent aber sein. Oder hast du schon in FIFA gespielt? Nee, extrem schlecht in FIFA. Ich habe FIFA 2013 gespielt und die Schwierigkeit so runtergestellt, dass ich mit dem Torwart von meinem Tor mit dem Ball einmal über das gesamte Spielfeld laufen kann, um in das gegnerische Tor nicht den Ball einz... Ball-Torwart-Tore zählen doppelt. Nicht den Ball zu schießen, sondern mit dem Ball ins Tor zu laufen. Das war mein höchstes Jugendglück. Und dann wurde der Ball wieder ausgeschlagen, dann bin ich wieder ins Tor gelaufen. Ich fand die Vorstellung einfach so lustig, dass er einfach läuft bis ins Tor, bis ins Netz, auch nicht langsamer wird, sondern so schnell er kann, ins Netz läuft und dann hängenbleibt wie so ein Thunfisch. Und dann einfach so ein Tor. Hängenbleiben wie so ein Thunfisch? Ja, wie so ein Thunfisch. Ist das so deine Kritik an einem Fischfang? Ich finde, es gibt viel zu wenig so Fischnamen. Es gibt ja dann so die Kölner Haie. Was? Gut, das ist ja echt Name Fisch, aber es gibt irgendwie nicht so die Kieler Flundern oder so irgendwie so die Bottropper Störe oder so. Aber der Eishockey ist wirklich ein Problem, weil du hast sehr coole Tiere, aber die sind dann irgendwann weg. Sondern hast du ... Ja, es stimmt schon vor allem ...
Die Iserlohn Roosters gibt es zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber die auf dem Eis, die Hähnchen, die Hähnchen.
Das ist nicht cool, wenn die gegen die Kölner Haie, ich bin generell immer für das coolere Tier einfach.
Ja.
Haie, ich brauche auch zum Beispiel das Haie.
Aber Haie gegen Eisbär?
Ja.
Aber dann gibt es die in Nürnberg, glaube ich, die Thomas-Sabo-Eistigers. Wo ich mir so Eis-Tigers vorstelle mit so Thomas-Sabo-Schmuck. Die sind ziemlich cool. Was ist ein Eistiger? Es gibt nicht jedes Tier noch mal in Eis. Nee, ich glaub, nee doch, aber das haben wir die blicken. Das ist nicht wie Kinder-Schokolade, wo es alles noch mal in weisser Schokolade gibt oder so, Twix gibt es in weiss. Ja, die Mannheim Space Horses. Die Polarbiene. Wow. Nee, es funktioniert nicht. Eisbiene. Eisvögel gibt es aber. Eisvögel. Naja. Wuh, Eisvögel. Naja, eine Eisvögel, der extra hier gepinkt pilgert ist, einfach so aus dem Südpol. Ja, das wäre dann derjenige, der uns so eine fiese Mail schreibt, wenn wir was über Eisvögel falsch sagen. Das ist das Problem mittlerweile, wir haben eine Hörerschaft erreicht, wo es für alles Experten gibt, zumindest einer, der sich auf dem Gebiet sehr gut auskennt. Das stimmt, aber es gibt nicht alle Tiere noch mal als Eis, es gibt nur so Fuchs. Wir bleiben bei dem Thema. Ich wollte, ich bin ja, wie hat, wie hat, wie hat, sagen wir jetzt mal, wir verwenschlichen jetzt mal die Evolution und nennen sie Paula, wie hat Paula entschieden, dass man sagt so, oh, Fuchs, oder, den macht man nochmal als Eisvariante, genauso wie den Bären, wohingegen die Schlange, nee, keine Eisschlange, einfach so, wie wurde das entschieden, dass die einfach nochmal so einen, wie so einen bösen Bruder kriegen, einfachfach so eine Paralleldimension. Gibt's ein Video, wie ein Fuchs einen Polarfuchs trifft? Und dann so awkward silence. Ja, dann ein Bären, ein Eisbär. Aber ist nicht, Moment, ganz kurz, sind nicht Eisbären, sind nicht Eisbären? die Evolution ist so fucking einstrengend. Es ist zu schwierig. Eisbär ist doch einfach eine Mutation von normalen Bären, die überlebt hat Survival of the fittest, die überlebt haben, weil sie im Winter nicht aufgefallen sind im Schnee. Nee, aber jetzt finde ich, jetzt bist du parteiisch. Wurden nicht gepressen, haben sich fortgepflanzt. Jetzt bist du parteiisch, jetzt sagst du, der Eisbär ist besser als der Bär.
Das kann ich so nicht unterschreiben.
Im Schnee.
Das stimmt nicht.
Die weisse Rasse ist die... Im Schnee! Wie wär's... Im Schnee die bessere Masse.
Stopp, stopp, stopp.
Was war daran jetzt verwerflich?
Folgende Idee, wir setzen Frauentausch ab und machen stattdessen Tiertausch, Polarfuchs tauscht eine Woche mit einem normalen Waldfuchs, wir filmen beide und beide wirklich so, oh hier gibt es nichts zu essen, das ist eine gute Idee, das ist eine gute Idee und dann guckt man, wer schlägt sich besser, das ist eine geile Idee. Ich glaube, beide sterben nach fünf Minuten.
Gut, eine Werbepause kriegst du rein, passt schon. Und danach machst du weiter, Eisbär und Braunbär tauschen sich und die Kinder so, oh man, ich will Schneeball spielen. Und überall hängen trotzdem diese Frauentausch-Post-its. So, mein Kleiner isst wieder nur Seelachs, die ganze Zeit Seelachs. Jafach Seelachs fangen und dem geben. Aber er mag das nicht, wenn man das vorher schon kaputt macht oder irgendwie aufschneidet, ausnimmt. Er mag es gerne so mit dem Dreh. Das hier ist eine Honigwabe. Eine was? Die kenne ich überhaupt nicht. Und dann diese Talking Heads dann immer geschnitten. Ich kam zunächst gar nicht klar. Ja, ich weiss, dieses Honigzeug, das hat mir wirklich überhaupt nicht geschmeckt.
Ja, und bei mir läuft immer so ein schartiger Song.
Und der Braunbär ist so, kann jemand hier leben. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Am Ende gibt es dann immer einen mega guten Happy End irgendwie, haben sich doch angefreundet oder so.
Oder der Braunbär startet durch mit dem Eisbärenvater oder so.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee. Oder am Ende tauschen sie wieder und dann kommt sie an der Texttafel und der Eisbär starb innerhalb von zwei Wochen wegen des Klimawandels. Ah, okay. Next. Wow. Und dann lernt man was und hat Spaß. Das wäre die relevanteste RTL2-Show. Ja, man muss das eigentlich jetzt noch machen, bevor die alle aussterben, oder? Wer ist, hat irgendwer einen guten Rat zu RTL2? Wir haben hier eine Menge an Leuten sitzen. Ja, wirklich? Ja, ne? Ne, ernsthaft jetzt. Nee, weil RTL2 wäre perfekt. Komm nach der Sendung zu uns. Ja. Stell dir vor, da wirklich RTL2-Internen sässt jetzt hier und würde dann wirklich kommen und mit uns Gespräche anfangen. So ein Tier Trash-TV zu machen. Ich finde das eine richtig gute Idee. In meinem Kopf stand gerade jemand, so ein glaskäufiger Mann mit so einem Anzug auf, geht zur Bühne und nimmt den Applaus mit und brüht sich die Hand. Und dann fiel mir einer bei RTL2, der hat wahrscheinlich keinen Anzug an. Ja, oder, oder, oder... Nee, nur jetzt mal in diesem fiktiven Szenario. Nein, nein, oder er schreibt sich sowas auf und schleicht sich dann so einfach ganz her. Und morgen dann direkt. Nächste Woche.
Tiertausch.
Gleich nach der Werbung, sehen Sie, die Polarbärer mögen keinen...
Eisvogel auf Vogel. Die tauschen ein Vogel und ein Eisvogel.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Das ist eine langweilige Folge, weil der Eisvogel auch hier lebt.
Der Braunbär ist festgefroren. Was macht er nun?
Ist so kalt. Nee, ist ihm wahrscheinlich nicht kalt, das ist nämlich genau das Ding. Ich glaube, dem Braunbären geht es einfach richtig scheiße und dem Eisbären einfach richtig gut. Und der Eisbär denkt sich, warum zur Hölle lebe ich im Schnee? Hallo, also jetzt schenke ich es erst. Ich lebe auf Eis und es gibt nichts zu essen. Die einzigen Menschen, die hier leben wollen, mich essen. Und die einzigen Kamaleute, die hier sind, sind da umzufilmen, wie ich verhungere. Ich bleib hier im Wald. Gut, dass er die Kameraleute gar nicht hinterfragt. Dann läuft er weg. Aber das stimmt, ich habe mich schon häufig gefragt, warum Eskimos, sorry, Inuit, nicht einfach direkt in wärmere Gefilde gezogen sind, warum die daran nichts ändern wollten. Wir brauchen 50 Wörter wie Schnee, haben sie sich überlegt. Aber sie haben keine für Wärme oder so oder Gemütlichkeit. Einfach mal überlegen, dass man vielleicht nicht da anfangen sollte. Warum muss man die ganze Arbeit machen und kann es einfach umziehen? Ich weiß es nicht, aber wenn du erstmal die ganzen Schlitten hast, dann kommst du ja auch nicht mehr damit an Land voran. Dann hast du die ganzen Huskys und die Schlitten. Das ist dann so wie diese armseligen... Ach du meinst, man ist zu lange in eine Richtung gelaufen und dann überlegt man sich, das macht keinen Sinn mehr. Das sind wie diese armseligen Skifahrer, die dann so über die Strasse stampfen, so mit ihren Ski, und sie einfach denken, du gehörst hier einfach nicht hin. Und so ist es in der Inuit-Gesellschaft auch, die haben dann diese Schlitten und haben Spaß, und den ganzen Tag Schlitten fahren, und die kämen in der Wüste gar nicht klar damit. Gut, Wüste ist auch nochmal ein Thema, können wir auch nochmal dr reden, warum da. Aber da gibt es auch so große Wüstenschuhe, wo man besser im Sand laufen kann. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber es ist, ich glaube, es ist... Ich weiss nicht, ich denke mir halt die ganze Zeit im Winter, ich habe einen dicken Pulli an, eine dicke Winterjacke, Mütze, Schal und mir ist immer noch kalt. Und ich will lieber rein, so. Und die haben daran nichts ändern wollen, die sind dann reingegangen in Eishütte, was auch aus Eis war. Boden war Eis, Bett war Eis, Decke war Eis. Endlich sind wir in unserer warmen Eishütte angekommen. Oh, ist kalt draußen, ist frisch geworden, oder, Schatz? Muckelig warm, kann ich noch ein bisschen näher an die Eisheizung gehen? Ja. Gibt es mit dem Tee vom Eisherd eben mal, das ist durch und durch eine schlechte Idee. Ja. Einfach, es funktioniert nicht. Und deren Tee ist einfach nur ein bisschen wärmer. Einfach so ein bisschen weicheres, so Slushie-Eis oder sowas. Ich weiss nicht. Oh ja. Vor allem, ich frage mich, warum gewinnen nicht solche Inuit-Völker so jedes Jahr beim Eisschnelllauf oder Eishockey oder sowas? Müssen die nicht super krass sein auf Eis oder so? Aber gar nichts, von denen kriegt man nicht viel mit. Gibt's da einen Podcast oder so, so einen Eis-Podcast? Weiss man auch nicht genau. Gegen den treten wir dann an bei Frauen, Eistausch. Ich habe das Gefühl, 2020 wird das Jahr von Antenne Antarktis. Und wir müssen mal wieder Einspieler anfordern. Wir sagen, hier gibt es nicht nur Eis. Hier gibt es auch Krebs, Unterwasserkrebs. Bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Ich habe ja jetzt unsere Erde angefangen auf Netflix, so diese Naturserie, die super krass ist, aber halt auch immer so mit so einem Augenzwinkern, so die sterben gleich alle. Aber es ist halt ... Augenzwinkern? Naja, ist vielleicht nicht die richtige Geste für die sterben gleich. Falscher Ausdruck gewesen. Vielleicht mit so einem Fingerschnippen so nebenbei. Fingerzeigen. Und da ist auch immer so diese Situation, du hast ja dieses Robbenbaby, das halt fast tot ist, und dann kommt der Eisbär, der dieses Robbenbaby fangen will, und dann hast du diese spannende Musik, und wo man auch einfach denkt, wie viele Takes waren das, wie oft haben die dieses Ding wieder aus dem Wasser gezogen, bis er es endlich kriegt so einfach, weil das ist ja, das ist so unmöglich zu filmen vor, dass sie das einfach auch beim ersten Take machen. Willst du es denn, dass er das tötet? Das ist ja die Frage, ich weiß es nicht genau, aber es war sehr cool. Du hättest es als Dokumentarfilmer besser gefunden, wenn er es tötet. Das ist doch eh alles gefakt, schau dir König der Löwen an, wie gut das aussieht. Das ist, glaube ich, gefakt. Du kannst alles faken. Ich glaube, da bist du einer grossen Sache auf der Spur. Man weiss es mittlerweile nicht mehr, was man anschaut, ob man den Film anschaut oder die Natur-Doku. Dass die genau dann filmen, wenn die alle singen. Wow, jetzt hat er seinen Text nicht mehr, seinen Text vergessen. Oh nein. Das ist die Natur. So ist das nun mal. Das ist nicht perfekt. Der Stürmer ist nicht perfekt. Der Stärkere überlebt. Es ist eine wilde Zeit. Nee, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht gefaked. Ich glaube nicht, dass die da Babys aus dem Eis ziehen und die dann davor werfen. Es ist doch auch schöner, wenn das Baby entkommt, oder? Das ist doch die Geschichte, die du erzählen willst. Ach, ich weiss es nicht, aber manchmal so mit so einem Besen noch mal so, komm, jetzt voran. Ist doch mal. Hundertprozentig, ja, ja, ihr wieder, die denkt, das ist alles so abgefilmt, das Fernsehen ist voller Lügen. Jede Sendung, genauso funktioniert Frauentausch auch, die werden auch mit so Besenstiel immer so angedotzt. Einfach so, mach was, mach was. Bei Gata ist auch ein grossen Skandal, dass bei Joko und Klaas Duell um die Welt haben ja findige Zuschauer Anschlussfehler entdeckt. Ich glaube, das war doch Sophia Tomala oder so,
wo man gesagt hat, dass sie
mehrere Tage unterwegs war in so einem Van
und dann hat man aber entdeckt,
dass sie ihre Fingernägel lackiert hat
und andere Klamotten anhatte
und die Polster in dem Van waren auch andere plötzlich.
Man hat aber behauptet, es wäre am gleichen Tag gewesen.
Hat die Bildzeit einen grossen Skandal rausgemacht.
War da ein Besen im Bild?
Na, auch so Sophia Tomala. Nee, aber hat man Sophia Tomala so eine Robbenbaby vorgebracht. Mal gucken, was passiert. Wüsste ich nicht. Tatsächlich, ich habe ja nicht allzu viel Erfahrung im Fernsehen gesammelt, aber meine Erfahrung ist, Fernsehen ist immer gefaked, ausser man denkt, dass es gefaked. Immer wenn man denkt, dass es gefaked, dann ist es tatsächlich echt, immer so, gerade so bei so Quiz-Sendungen oder so, wo man denkt, das ist alles abgesprochen, die wissen das schon im Vorhinein oder so, da ist es echt, aber wo man denkt, es ist echt. Also das nächste Mal, wenn ihr denkt, oh, das ist doch gefakt, denkt, es ist echt, und wenn ihr denkt, es ist echt, dann denkt, es ist gefakt. Einfach mal umdrehen. Denkt generell immer das Gegenteil. Ja, 2020. Vielleicht die Lehre daraus. Bei 2020 passt das perfekt. Bei 2020 könnt ihr einfach mal umdrehen, Dann sagt ihr einfach mal 2020, aber sagt das erste 20 vor dem anderen. Zweiten 20 und macht mal 2020 einfach so ein Backflipjahr. Das grosse Wechseljahr. Ja, wo man einfach umdreht. Dreht mal die Matratze um. Sorry. Das falsche Wort. Das erste. Das falsches mögliche Wort. Macht 2020 zu eurem Wechseljahr. Einfach mal wechseln. In der Kampagne arbeiten wir noch. Sind die Fuster schon gedrückt? Sind die Flyer schon gedrückt? Ja, es ist, wir haben leider zu viel Geld da schon in den Reihen. Es ist zu schwierig. Es ist eine schwierige Situation. Was muss man tun moralisch im Leben? Was muss man tun? Oder kann man sich auch zurücklehnen und sagen, oh, jetzt habe ich es vergessen? Oder muss man, wann muss man anfangen, moralisch zu sein? Weil so Kinder denkt man so scheiße. Ich habe es ein bisschen im Alter, wo man schon ein bisschen mitdenken sollte, was man so im Alltag tut. Ich habe jetzt noch, ich habe eine private Frage an euch. Wer von euch hat noch dieses Zahnarzt-Bonus-Heft? Die gleichen zwei Leute, es sind immer die Ich glaube, also es zeigen ein paar auf, ich schätze mal so fünf Prozent des Publikums, werden wir alle verarscht, weil ich habe das Gefühl, weil ich habe es jemandem erzählt, weil ich laufe die ganze Zeit noch mit so einem Bonus, so einem Stempelheft rum, das ist so ein alter Fetzen, der ist uralt schon, den kriegt man als Kind, damit man jedes Jahr zum Zahnarzt geht und Versicherungen am Ende bezahlt, weil man halt jedes Jahr nachweislich vom Zahnarzt war, kriegt man jedes Jahr einen Stempel vom Zahnarzt. Ich, mit 25 Jahren, habe immer noch dieses bescheuerte Stempelheft und ich komme mir vor wie so ein, wie immer so ein Diddl-Sammelalbum, der immer so durch die Gegend rennt, mit seinem Transformers-Rucksack und dann beim Zahnarzt das abgibt. Und es ist wieder Ende des Jahres und deswegen deswegen wurde ich neulich von meiner Mutter erinnert, als sie mir dann dieses Schlüsselding umgehangen hat und mein Portemonnaie umhalsgegangen hat. Sie hat ihren Zettel in die Brotbox gelegt. Hat sie gesagt, denk doch bitte daran, dass du das Bonusheft abstempeln lässt. Und ich dachte mir, wann hört das denn auf? Weil ich vergesse auch jedes Jahr von der Existenz des Bonusheftes. Vielleicht ist es aber 25 Jahre das letzte Jahr, weiß ich nicht. Also bin ich dann zum Zahnarzt gelaufen und hab dann das Bonusheft abgegeben, hab auch Freunde davon vorher erzählt, und Kollegen, und niemand hatte dieses Bonusheft. Und da dachte ich mir, was ist das denn jetzt los? Und da bin ich zum Zahnarzt, hab das abgegeben und hab gesagt, ja, ich bräuchte noch einen Stempel für 2019. Und da hat sie auch kurz Pianco-Kurz und hat mir dann so einen Stempel gegeben, habe mich dann noch gefragt, ob ich so einen roten Lolli will, dann kann ich gehen. Aber ich verstehe das wirklich nicht, also weil ich glaube, dass man uns, Leute trauen sich nicht, uns allen, die gerade aufgezeigt haben, zu sagen, dass man das nicht mehr braucht. Man kann einfach im Internet, also warum, vor allem, die Leute wissen doch, Krankenkassen wissen doch wissen doch auch Dinge, die geben ja ein, die scannen die Karte ja auch und so. Warum braucht man doch diesen händischen Stempel? Ja, es stimmt schon, du kriegst dann so einen schönen kleinen Bärchenstempel. Ja. Und dann so bei der Versicherung, kann ich das was von kaufen? Ich habe jetzt schon fünf Bärchenstempel. Ja, Sie können sich aussuchen. Sie können das Stickerheft haben für vier Stempel oder das Kuscheltier für sechs. Was denn für ein Kuscheltier? Das ist ein kleines Bärchen, das hat statt Augen kleine Herzen. Ich dachte schon, Karius und Baktus oder so. Nee, dafür brauchen sie acht Herzchen jeweils. Wer war der Gute? Beide sind nicht gut, ne? Nee, sind beide böse tatsächlich. Baktus? Beide böse. Brüder oder gar nicht verwandt? Das ist so ein bisschen wie Hitler und Stalin. Was? Jeder hat seine eigene Meinung, wer schlimmer war, aber man sollte sie nicht öffentlich sagen. Aber wir alle wissen, wer es war. Oder nicht? Nee. Jeder von euch nickt. Und so ist Karius und Baktus auch so. Klar, der eine hat was angestellt, aber der andere halt auch. So, das ist so das Problem. Ja, weil ich hab das nicht, weil da hat auch noch jemand gesagt, wir hatten an der Schule damals zwei Maskottchen, die uns dann das Zähneputzen beigetragen haben, es waren Karies und Baktus. Und ich dachte mir, das sind Spione. Das sind zwei Bösewichte, die er hat. Vielleicht solltest du mal hinterfragen, wie du deine Zähneputzen, wenn sowohl Karies als auch Baktus die erklärt haben und es gar keine Opposition gab zu Karies und Baktus, wenn er nicht noch Mr. Elmax um die Ecke gekommen ist. Was für fucking Arschlöcher, wie selbstsicher müssen die sich fühlen, dass sie sagen, komm wir bringen den Kindern noch Zähneputzen bei, die haben eh keine Chance gegen uns. Ja, aber die bringen das falsch bei, die müssen so diagonal oder so. Das ist schon krass. Ich finde das schwierig. Das sind wie diese McDonald's-Initiativen, die dann gesundes, gesundes Ernährungs-Kindern beibringen wollen, einfach die wissen ganz genau so, das funktioniert nicht, aber wir machen es. Naja, ich habe nur mein scheiß Bonusheft und ich laufe noch bis 40 mit diesem Stempelheft rum, ich sag's ihr. Da ist noch so viel Platz für Stempel. Ja, aber kriegt man das jemals voll oder muss man dann so die Formen machen? Nee, nee, man, nee, du hast auf jeder Seite so Stempeldinger. Ich finde auch lustig, wenn die einfach irgendwann so eintragen. Mein Schwarm, mein Lieblingsfilm. Was ich mal werden möchte. Ja, wenn so jeder Arzt, ja, jeder Arzthelfer kann man dann immer so ein bisschen was für sich erzählen. Wird schön. Was hast du ins Poesiealbum geschrieben, bei Was ich mal werden möchte? Ähm, Podcaster. Oh, wirklich? Der siebenjährige Stefan. Ich möchte meinen eigenen RSS-Feed haben. Oh, der kleine Stefan. Nee, ich war ein Klassiker, Polizei, war er mal ein Astronaut. Ja? Bäcker. Bäcker? Nein. Nein, komm schon, niemand wird Bäcker. Nein, ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, bei Kindern ist die Umurteilung von Berufen ganz anders. Es gibt auch viele Kinder, die Müllmänner werden wollen, aber Bäcker ist auch hoch im Kurs. Stell dir mal vor, schon so ein richtig gut duftendes Brot, und das halt den ganzen Tag. Ja, ja. Und Snacks. Und Center-Shocks, wenn niemand hinschaut. Einiges Bäcker, der beste Beruf, den es gibt. Es war ein Jahr, glaube ich, da gab es in jedem Bäcker Center-Shock. So einen Behälter. Wo ich glaube, er möchte auch nicht sagen. Ich meine, natürlich machen die Mitarbeiter sich auch eigene Burger, oder? So einfach, fuck it, wir machen einfach einen Burger mit 16 Scheiben Käse und dann nur noch Zwiebelringe. Einfach so fuck it, man probiert es einfach aus. Wild Burger. Dürfte man nicht auch als Kind sich einen eigenen Burger wünschen, wenn man Geburtstag hatte? Ich glaube, das machen die mittlerweile nicht mehr, weil da zu viele Leute gestorben sind daran. Mein Burger hat zehn Patties. Ich bin da also. Hallo. Hallo, guten Tag. Guten Tag. Jene, 16. Drei Tomaten. Ich diktiere. Zum Nektat. Drei Tomaten. Jawohl, ist notiert. Cheddar. Ist notiert. Nochmal Cheddar. Ja. Gruyère-Käse, Parmesan, Tomate. Aber es hat funktioniert. Man hat es bekommen. Ich habe es noch nie gesehen. Doch, doch, doch, doch. Das gab es. Man dürfte sich als Geburtstagskind, dürfte man sich Burger wünschen. Aber als Kind ist man ja so dumm. Man sagt dann, ich hätte gerne Hamb Hamburger ohne Gurke, so wo man sich denkt,
so du Depp, warum nimmst du Sachen weg? Das Wort ohne sollte nicht vorkommen auf deiner Wunschliste.
Mach doch einfach einen McRib mit 17 McRib-Patties.
Ja, oder so McRib mit einem Fish Mac noch da drin.
Ja, genau. Ich hätte gerne einen Hamburger, aber statt der Gurke einen Big Mac. Ja, so das. Das hätte ich gern. Okay. Happy Birthday. Oder so krasse Wünsche, so Onion Rings, aber als Kette. Ja. Das heißt, dass sie so ineinander verzahnt sind.
Das statt dem Patty auf meinem Royal TS, bitte.
Ich glaube, es war einfach zu kompliziert.
Ich glaube, irgendjemand hat das einfach geknackt und gesagt,
ja, ich hätte irgendwie da, keine Ahnung, 2000 Euro drauf und Vertragsrecht schmusslich geben.
Ich hätte gerne unendlich mehr Wünsche und dann alle, ja, ciao, Rollladen runter.
Was kann ich essen, damit ich möglichst viel ins Bällebad kotze? Nicht schon wieder. Immer war das gesperrt bei mir, war immer Bällebad gesperrt, immer aus irgendeinem Grund, weil jemand gestorben ist. So lange nicht mehr im Bällebad, kann man im Bällebad stehen? Wie tief sind Bällebäder? Kommt darauf an, wie groß du bist. Oder haben Bällebäder ... Naja, wenn du dich auf den Leichen der anderen
Kindern abstützt, kann man hier schon stehen. Da sterben wirklich jährlich vierzigtausend
Kinder. Ja? Ja, wirklich alle fünf so da. Ganz kurz, könnte man nicht so alle Todesursachen, wenn man die so hintereinander legt, so eine Symphonie machen, so aus allen Todesursachen. You haven't found ... Ja, Krebs, ja, zu viel Wasser ist auch eine todeslose Sache. Pass auf, nicht zu viel Wasser. Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs. Herz und Herz, Krebs. Ich glaube, es funktioniert gut. Ich glaube, wir könnten richtig viel Geld einnehmen. Krankheiten das Musical. Alles zusammen, alles übereinander. Finde ich gut. Krankheiten das Musical finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Ja, stimmt schon.
Aids ist halt der ultimative Endgegner, so, und die anderen Krankheiten kämpfen nur um ihren Ruf.
So will man aber gefährlichere Krankheiten sein.
So Kindermusicals, wo man auch was lernt.
Diabetes, erst süss, dann tödlich.
Du isst zu viele, nimm zwei, danach isst du gar nichts mehr, deine Mutter steht am Grab und weint. Nimm die fetten Finger aus dem Popcorn, nimm sie schneller raus, sonst greifst du nichts mehr, denn du bist tot. Ich bin die Meningitis, die hast du dir eingefangen, im Pfadfinderlager diese eine Zecke.
Ich bin der Virus, dam dam dam, ich klopfe an die Tür, doch keiner macht mir auf wegen Impfung. Impfung, Impfung, Impfung. Ja, Impfung ist eigentlich eine geile Probe, wie so eine Generalprobe für den Körper, wo man einmal kurz, man spielt es mal durch. Ja, das stimmt. Wie so eine Feuerübung. Es ist ein bisschen wie eine Komplettlösung. Eigentlich ist es Impfen, Cheaten. Eigentlich ist es Impfen, Cheaten. Das ist, wie wenn das neue Zelda rauskommt und du schaust dir der Vorstand in Let's Play an. Komplettlösung an. Und du denkst so, was wirst du, kenne ich schon. Locker, hier hinten die Bombe und dann klättest du da hoch und dann kann dir die Krankheit nichts mehr anhaben, weil du weißt schon, wie es läuft. Was ist deine Lieblingskrankheit? Das ist hart, das ist schwer, das ist schwer. Gut, Top fünf. Ja, okay, okay. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Gut, welche Kategorien denn? Also ist die Frage, jetzt im Sinne von tödlich, im Sinne von Coolness. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, nee, es gibt, es gibt eine Krankheit, wo dein Magen falschrum ist, die hat keine weiteren Auswirkungen, nur dass dein Magen falschrum ist.
Wie jetzt, aber einmal so...
Ja, der ist halt so gedreht.
Ich hätte fast gesagt, einmal um 360 Grad gedreht.
Nee, es gibt so bei manchen Leuten...
Also relativrum hat keine Auswirkungen.
Geht der Magen so rechts, links, rechts, über andere so links, rechts, links. Das war's. Das war einfach schon alles.
Es gibt doch Leute, die haben das Herz auf der falschen Seite. Ja? Oder richtigen. Hitler. Oh! Die Obduktion. Ach, deswegen! Oh! Dr. Marc Benecke so, da haben wir's. Da haben wir's doch. Ich hatte schon eine Theorie, bringt das Luminol! Luminol! Yeah, Callbacks. Callbacks aus der vorletzten Folge.
Wie oft müssen wir ihn erwähnen, dass er mal ins Podcast-Uvo kommt?
Ich weiss es nicht genau.
Ich glaube, wir müssen ihn einfach mal fragen.
Lass uns Leute mal Benneke mal einladen. Ich glaube, der ist toll.
Ich glaube schon, der erzählt uns viel. Werbung Weihnachtszeit ist Friedenszeit, und alle Parteien, die sich das ganze Jahr bekämpfen, kommen an Weihnachten friedlich zusammen, so auch die vielleicht grösste Fede, die Deutschland kennt. Aldi Nord und Aldi Süd, ausser zu Weihnachten, denn da verbrüdern sich beide Parteien, um das ganz besondere Weihnachtsfest zu feiern, mit den ganzen Aldi-Weihnachtsklassikern. Eine Weihnachtsgans. Lamm.
Lametta. Schmuck, Weihnachtsschmuck. Ich glaube, man kann einfach zu Aldi gehen und sich perfekt ausrüsten für die Feiertage. Das ist toll, du musst nur zu Aldi gehen, da findest du alles. Alles, was du bei Aldi nicht findest, brauchst du auch nicht für Weihnachten. Genau, es gibt sehr viele Filialen, das steht für Qualität, Aldi steht für Frische. Warst du denn auch schon auf aldiventskalender.de? Da kannst du wie jedes Jahr ganz tolle Preise gewinnen.
Also unbedingt vorbeischauen auf aldiv-wenzkalender.de und schau mal Aldi vorbei für die tollen Weihnachtangebote. Wow, ich freue mich noch mehr auf Weihnachten, das wird ein tolles Fest zusammen mit Aldi. Werbung. Aber zum Thema moralisch verwerflich. Ich hatte heute einen moralischen Konflikt, ich war in einem Kommand...
Und es ist nicht ganz einfach, aber oft zu moralischen Konflikten ist es ja oft so, dass sie jeder kennt.
Ich glaube, diesen moralischen Konflikt kennt niemand, er ist sehr, sehr speziell.
Nicht relatable. Das kennen wir heute von uns.
Und zwar habe ich auf Twitter abonniert, ich folge auf Twitter dem Auschwitz Memorial.
So, weil ich mir dachte, so, das gehört dazu, muss man sich mal anschauen. Warum, weil was da jährlich passiert eigentlich für... Ja, die posten ganz gutes Zeug, ganz gute Memes. Jetzt posten die aber jetzt, jetzt posten die aber recht viel. Und jetzt war ich heute kurz, wo ich mir überleg, kann man dem Auschwitz-Memorial entfolgen? Ja, kann ich sagen, nee du, wir hatten eine gute Zeit. Aber da kommt dann Bild, bild.de irgendwie, spitzfindig. Es ist gut, ich habe bei Twitter gestellert, Florentin Will hat Auschwitz-Memorial deabonniert. Ja, gefällt Florentin Will nicht mehr. Wo man einfach so denkt aber auf der anderen seite dachte ich mir so nein das ist meine historische verantwortung als
deutscher muss ich dem twitter-account von ausschwitz folgen das ist das mindeste was
ich tun kann und ich habe es nicht übers herz gebracht zu entfolgen und jetzt muss ich den
ganzen scheiß halt weiter ertragen aber ich bin nach dass wenn man einmal folgst du kommst nicht
mehr raus es funktioniert einfach nicht mehr es gibt hundertprozentig eine einzige person die Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Aber ich bin nach, dass wenn du einmal folgst, du kommst nicht mehr raus. Es funktioniert einfach nicht mehr. Du kommst nicht mehr raus. Es gibt hundertprozentig eine einzige Person, der es exakt genauso geht. Ich weiss es, irgendwo in der Dunkelheit sitzt du und reibst deine Hände jetzt, weil du genau weisst, scheiße, ich kann dem auch nicht entfolgen. Es geht nicht, du bist da einfach drin. Du kommst da nicht mehr raus. Aber frag dich doch mal vorsichtig, ob du dich vielleicht blockieren. Oder kann ich euch schreibe so lange, das ist ja noch schlimmer, die Muten schreibt. Oh, nehmt denen die Stimme, die eh schon keine haben, aber ja, oder schreibt so lange, macht die so an von der Seite, dass sie vielleicht, oder schreibt so lange so rechten Scheiss, müsst ihr dich irgendwann blockieren. Ja, es ist es ist es vielleicht besser, als den aktiv zu entfolgen. Nein, ich glaube nicht. Sorry, ist ein Brainstorming. Ich weiß auch nicht, Ja, ja,ing. Ich krieg dich da nicht raus aus den Normen. Nein, es ist schwierig. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie die da rauskommen. Ich glaube, ich muss einfach einen neuen Twitter-Account machen. Und dann direkt Bernd Luckel. Nur noch Ralf Schmitz folgen, nur noch den lustigen Leuten, die gute Sachen posten und nicht dann irgendwie zu ernst werden. Ist ja schwierig so, auf Social Media hast du in einem Feed das gesamte menschliche Emotionsspektrum und es passt nicht zusammen so, du kannst es ja nicht alles zusammen, du schaust ja auch nicht eine Doku an über irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Elvis, dann geht es wieder um Stalin, dann geht es wieder um irgendeinen Hungertod und dann geht es wieder um die Spice Girls. Wenn es nach meinen YouTube-Vorschlägen geht, geht es genauso liebig zu gucken. Du stellst dich ja emotional auf sowas ein, aber bei Social Media kriegst du immer so süße Katze und dann, ah die sind alle tot. Auch der Hund versucht die Glebtreppe hoch zu klettern, also das ist ja, ja stimmt, da müsst ihr auch mal wieder spenden, ja scheisse. Fuck. Und gut, dass du von denen dann so genervt bist, dass du die entfolgen willst. Ja genau, die müssen raus, ist zu viel. Vielleicht sind die Mimes das Problem. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Nicht immer nur lachen. Vielleicht braucht man ernstes Social Media, so ein Social Media fürs Gewissen. Wo du ein Profilbild hast, wo du auch nicht lachst. Sehr genau, wo alle ganz ernst sind und sich nur über ernste Sachen unterhalten. Ja, wo so nachdenklich sind. So ein B-Twitter, so ein ironiefreies Twitter vielleicht. Ja, ich weiss es nicht, es ist schwer.
Es ist eine schwere Zeit. Facebook ist eigentlich ironiefreies Twitter, oder nicht? Ja, ich weiss es nicht. Ich bin in Facebook in zu viel Verschwörungsseiten drin, ich bin mittlerweile zu tief gefangen. Ich habe mittlerweile angefangen, die zu liken aus Interesse, aus Rechercheinteressen. Mittlerweile ist es das Hauptsächliche, was ich lese auf Facebook, und der Algorithmus checkt das halt und gibt mir nur noch Verschwörungszeug und alles andere geht runter. Aber muss ich mir als dein Co-Host da Gedanken machen, weil wir verbringen ja schon viel Zeit miteinander und da schon Angst, dass du vielleicht in so eine Richtung abdriftest. Nein, es ist eine Frage der Zeit, bis bei irgendeiner Theorie kommen, die du cool findest. Ich kriege halt das andere Zeug nicht mehr mit, so dann sagt irgendwie der Bruder so, ah cool, unser Cousin hat ein Kind bekommen, ah ja ja ja, klar, wo genau, irgendwo, dann so ein ganz kleiner Post zwischen 9-11 und Mudflood und irgendwie JFK und JFC, so ganz klein, einfach so, hallo übrigens, dein Cousin hat ein Kind bekommen, ich komme da nicht mehr raus, ich glaube, das muss man einfach verbrennen, man muss manchmal einfach seine Social Media Accounts hinter sich verbrennen. Löschen, neu machen. Ja, 2020 ist für mich ein Jahr des Neuanfangs. Ich fange nochmal von vorne an. Gut, wir haben schon, also 2020 ist Wechseljahr, 2020 Neuanfang. Jahr des Neuanfangs, es ist das Jahr der Reime, ne, 2020. Nein, nein, das ist das gleiche Wort. Das gleiche Wörter reimen sich nicht. Ich bin schon, wir können mal wieder anfangen zu reimen. Das habe ich dir beim Freestyle schon ein paar Mal erzählt. Du kannst nicht das gleiche Wort. Das gleiche Wörter reimen sich nicht. Wir können mal wieder anfangen zu reiben. Das habe ich dir beim Freestyle schon ein paar Mal erzählt. Du kannst nicht das gleiche Wort nehmen nochmal. Deswegen verlierst du auch immer bei diesen ganzen Freestyle-Wettbewerbungen. Ja, es ist schwierig, aber ich suche mir immer absichtlich Worte, die extrem schwer ... wo man ... okay, komm, gib mir mal ein Beat. Okay, pass auf. Okay, pass auf. Das geht ab. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Okay, okay, pass auf, pass auf. Achtung, gib mir noch eine Sekunde. Okay, okay, pass auf, pass auf, Achtung, gib mir noch eine Sekunde, gib mir eine Sekunde, okay? Gib mir eine Sekunde, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, gib mir eine Sekunde noch. Okay, gleich habe ich es, gleich habe ich es, gleich habe ich es, yo, yo, yo, was geht, gleich habe ich es, Achtung, okay, hier kommt's, Achtung. Hey, yo, hier ist das Podcast UFO mit Drop so co ... Du droppst so coole Lines wie Smudo. Nee, ist ja cool, ich weiss es nicht. Leute, macht's gut, ciao, ich behofft noch. Das ist so cool, wie wild. In der ersten Line UFO. Was heißt sie auf UFO? Ähm ... Tofu. Grob. Es reimt sich grob.
Da kommt ein Schiedsrichter, der sagt, unreiner Reim, aber es geht, glaube ich.
Ja, Entschuldigung, das war in Jambos, eigentlich war da ein Trocheus vorgesehen.
Gibt es da auch, wie beim Boxen, so drei Richter, die entscheiden müssen?
Ja, ja.
Einen Richter und zwei Schöffen, die entscheiden, wer gewonnen hat, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe bis jetzt nur nein Mile, ne Five Mile, wie ist der mit Eminem, na, Eight Mile, sorry, mit den ganzen Sequels ist es immer schwierig, da durchzublenken. Oh, Nine Mile. Von Eight Mile, das ist der einzige Rap-Film, den ich gesehen habe, im Musikunterricht, das war unser Musikunterricht, einfach zu sagen, hier ist ein Film über Rap.
Und ich habe nur fünf
bekommen, weil ich
die ganze Zeit geredet habe, weil ich es so
cool fand, wie die so getan haben.
Ihr habt Eight-Miles-Musikunterricht geguckt?
Ein Eight-Miles-Musikunterricht? Wir haben mit so diesen
Klanghölzern
aufeinander gehauen, bis die Stunde vorbei war.
Was wir aber nicht gehört haben,
weil es so ein Läuf geklappert hat. Tagelang saßt ihr da in diesem Musikraum und habt Krach gemacht die ganze Zeit. Hattet ihr auch immer diese Röhren? Wir hatten immer diese Röhren, so riesenbunte Röhren, die sind unterschiedlich laut, äh hoch. Und dann hat man die nacheinander betätigt und hat man die halt, je nachdem, was für eine Melodie man erzählen wollte, Leuten in die Hand gedrückt und dann muss man so man die dann auslösen. Hat nie funktioniert, weil es immer einen unmusikalischen Vollidioten gibt, natürlich, und bei dem bleibt dann diese Kette hängen. Dann ist immer so fucking Dennis! Jesus Christ, Dennis am Handy wieder. Jeden Tag Geburtstag, auch einfach, das ist schrecklich. Ne Wir haben tatsächlich Sing-Star gespielt, auch im Unterricht.
Je mehr Highscore man hatte, desto besser war die Note. Es war eigentlich ein ganz einfaches, sehr simples pädagogisches Prinzip. Was hast du für einen Song gesungen? Immer Back to Black von Andy Winehouse, immer Back to Black, weil es ist glaube ich hauptsächlich eine Note die ganze Zeit und man kann das dann so kommen. Welche Note ist es? Und es gab hundert Punkte, es war wirklich dann so komplette Punktzahl, ja. Man hat dann irgendwie herausgefunden, was genau man machen muss, um da den Highscore zu bekommen. Ich glaube nicht singen primär, sondern so Murmeln, also die Lyrics glaube ich zu singen ist schon falsch. Nii, ni, ni, ni, ni, ni, ni, ni, ni, ni, ni, ja ist der technische Singische Sinn kein Sing, wenn sie nur nini, nini, nini, nii machen. Die Streber dann die ganze Zeit, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne Hand gegeben hat oder so, wirklich einer, der so knallharter Hardcore-Musiktyp war, der wirklich so das Leben von Händel abgefragt hat. Wir hatten genau die Mitte und er hat immer im Klavier gesessen und immer eingezählt, aber immer so sehr Musiklehrer sorgfältig, er hat immer gesagt, oh, eins, zwei, drei, vier, hit me baby, one more time on. Aber immer so schmissige Songs, also moderne schmissige Songs, aber mit diesem Musiklehrer hochgezogene Augenbrauen und bedacht auf den richtigen Auftakt. Hit me baby, one more time on, eins. All the single ladies und los. Ja, die Haare fluchen, ja, und alle tanzen. Gute Zeit, da war ja gute Zeit. Das finde ich ganz gut, das hat immer Spaß gemacht. Es ist aber schwer, Kinder für irgendwas zu begeistern. Die wollen einen ganzen Tag, es ist schwer, da solche Sachen an die anzubringen. Wenn die das nicht von selber mitbringen, ist es immer schwierig. Wofür plädiest du gerade eigentlich? Als Kind, ich plädiere für wenige Kinder, die müssen weg. Einfach so, das ist ein Konzept, das hat sich nicht durchgesetzt oder so. Keine Ahnung. doch, wäre doch für alle besser. Ich glaube, irgendwann kommen die eh in so ein Gelee rein für acht Jahre und dann werden die dann so krass gezüchtet und dann kommen die raus und dann können die alles und dann geht's los. So, dass man diese Kindheit einfach auslagert, irgendwie so eine externe Firma, so eine private Firma, die machen das, Kindheit.de und die machen das. Was darfst du angenommen, man entscheidet irgendwann, findet man heraus, wie man nicht mehr altert. Also man gibt Menschen so eine Spritze und dann altern die nicht mehr. Was glaubst du, in welchem Alter wird das mit Menschen gemacht dann? Weil volljährig ist man ja ab 18. Also du fragst mich, in welchem Alter möchtest du pausieren, sagen? In welchem Alter möchtest du ein? Nee, ich frage eher dich als Weltbürgermeister, der jetzt entscheiden muss. Ach so, habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. War die Wahl schon oder was? Was? War die Wahl schon oder was? Ich habe es gar nicht mitbekommen. Die Wahl waren gestern. Die haben mich gewählt. Ach, du scheit, okay. Du warst der Einzige, der sich aufgestellt hat. Ja, ich weiß. Ich dachte, man kann da was gewinnen. Okay, gut. So, ich würde gerne von Ihnen jetzt wissen, weil wir haben jetzt, wie gesagt, diese Spritze. Wem sollen wir die reinrammen? Jetzt einzelne Personen oder welchen Bevölkerungsgruppen? Wie gesagt, Sie können die ganze Menschheit, Sie können beschliessen, dass die Menschheit nicht mehr altert. Sagen Sie mir einfach dieses scheiss Datum, sagen Sie mir das ja, sagen Sie mir das Alter. Der Typ von der Kinderschokolade, lasst uns den einfrieren, der soll nicht altern, ich will nicht, dass der altert. Der soll sein Kleidungszüge, findet ihn und friert ihn ein, ich will, dass der Kleidungszüge bleibt. Oh mein Gott, aber sie sind doch... Gib mir Beyonce, natürlich. Was? Beyonce soll nicht mehr altern und ja, die Teletubby-Darsteller, dass man die einfach mal findet und die einfriert.
Ich finde, die haben viel zu wenig Anerkennung bekommen.
Lass uns die einfrieren. Okay? Okay?
Hier noch ein paar Fragen.
Ja, nee, ich muss auch los. Ich muss los.
Wo müssen Sie denn hin?
Ferien. Gerade beschlossen, ab jetzt sind Ferien. Haben Sie es nicht mitbekommen?
Ferien jetzt.
Wen, wen würden Sie denn...
Ciao!
Fliegt weg. Gab es eigentlich mal irgendein Staatsoberhaupt, das keinen Bock mehr hatte? Ich glaube ja. Also dann sagt man ja so, ja, ich muss zurücktreten wegen Skandal hier und da, aber gab es mal einer, der sagt so, boah, ich habe mir das ganz anders vorgestellt. Sorry, ich nehme es nochmal zurück, ich dachte, es wäre cool, lassen wir das? Ich glaube, das äussert sich immer in so Sachen, die man dann macht, um dann abgewählt zu werden. So hier Bill Clinton zum Beispiel, er hat doch einfach keine Lust mehr wahrscheinlich. Moment, du wirst noch mal ein komplett neues Licht auf die Lewinsky-Affäre. Ja, ich dachte, vielleicht hat er das einfach alles gestartet, weil er keinen Bock mehr hatte. Ja? Nee, das ist natürlich nicht der, was ich denke. Du, ich habe Bock auf Verschwörungstheorien, mach weiter, mach weiter. Ich bin ja total dran, ich kenne ein paar Leute. Du, das hat jetzt schon 2000 Likes auf Facebook, hundertprozentig total die Chancen. Das Klinken gesagt, ich habe keinen Bock mehr und dann gesagt hat, ja, würde man das aber leaken, ist das nicht ein bisschen zu peinlich? Ist schon peinlich. Oder für Hitler auch einfach keinen Bock mehr, hat sich überlegt, komme ich da auf meine ganz falsche Richtung. Ja, womit komme ich noch alles durch? Ihr macht das, okay, alles klar? Schwierig. Ich meine, man war selber erstaunt. Ja. What? Naja, ja, ist es ein bisschen zu hart, sorry. Ist ein schwieriges Thema. Nee, Hitler war, ist ein schwieriges Thema einfach. Aber auch lustig. Sehr kontroverse Aussage. Hitler war ein schwieriges Thema. Podcast auf morgen, so Stuttgarter Lokalzeitung. Ja, genau. Weil der Journalist bis zu dieser Stelle geblieben ist und dann gegangen ist. Hitler war ein schwieriges Thema. Das Podcast-Ufo kommt live in Stuttgart. Aber verrückte Sachen tatsächlich, wenn man sich da mal ein bisschen einliest. Man kriegt ja immer nur so ein bisschen das Best-of der deutschen Geschichte mit, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt. Aber da ist viel weirder zeug auch wo der worst of ja okay gut man weiß es nicht genau die creme de la creme sagen wir mal wertfrei da müssen wir wertfrei zum Beispiel total weirder Aktionen ich habe mich vor kurzem ein bisschen mit mit Rudolf Hess beschäftigt und das war so ein weirder Typ der irgendwann gesagt hat fuck it ich will jetzt Frieden mit England und ist alleine nach England geflogen, aus Deutschland, ist mit dem Fallschirm da abgesprungen und hat gesagt, ich will jetzt auf eigene Faust Frieden vereinbaren.
Total weirde Story, habe ich noch nie gehört, hundert Verschwörungstheorien da rum, aber das ist so eine Geschichte, die kriegt man sehr selten mit, aber das war total strange und dann haben die danach gesagt von wegen so, ja, das sieht schlecht für uns aus, dass einer von uns da rüber fliegt und dann haben die öffentlich gesagt, dass der wahnsinnig ist und dann haben sie gemerkt, das ist vielleicht keine so gute Idee zu behaupten, dass einer der führenden Nazis wahnsinnig war und haben das dann wieder zurückgezogen und gesagt, nee, doch nicht. Sorry, grosses Sorry, da haben wir uns verrannt. Ist ne tolle Geschichte, ich glaube, da könnte man ne coole Serie draus machen. Jetzt mal nur so, falls der RTL2-Typ noch hier ist.
Schreibt mal auf. Das ist das erste RTL-2-Original machen. Schreib mal auf Tiertausch und… hm… Dead Ass oder so. Dead Ass, Shake Dead Ass oder so. Ist ein Arbeitstitel, ist ein Arbeitstitel. Ist jetzt nicht so wichtig, der Titel ist nicht so wichtig. Es gibt schon verrückte Staatsformen so. Ameisen zum Beispiel. Ein Hügel? Das ist deren Idee? Ein Haufen? Ich meine, es ist ein Haufen. Warum bauen wir Termiten? Die bauen so geile Architektur. Ja. Ist das schon mal aufgefallen? Nee. Ich sag nicht. Termitenhügel, hast du die mal gesehen? Nee, keine Ahnung. Nein? Nee. Machst du gerade einen Scherz? Nee, wirklich. Da habe ich tatsächlich, gestehe ich hier. Hier sind abgefahrene Bauten aus, wie so eine ganz andere Architektur. Bisschen so wie Ameisenhügel, nur man hat sich halt so ein bisschen mehr mit mehr Pfiff ein bisschen mehr ausgedacht.
Du bist schon wieder Partei, Stefan, ich habe das Gefühl, du hast dein Lieblingstier einfach. Nee, ich finde Termiten einfach nur spannender. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, mit mehr Pfiff, das kannst du doch nicht sagen, das ist viel zu wert. Das kann man doch unseren Ameisen nicht antun. Das ist doch kein biologischer Begriff, Pfiff. Ne, was mir neulich zu Ohren gekommen ist, das ist in China, hat man sich überlegt, eine ganz tolle Idee hatte man da, wie man Leute dafür bestraft, dass sie über Rot gehen. Und zwar hat man sich überlegt, man hängt an den Ampeln Kameras auf und dann fotografiert man die Leute, die über Rot gehen, mit Gesichtserkennung und so, und dann zeigt man, gibt es grosse Bildschirme neben den Ampeln, wo dann so diashow-mäßig die Gesichter gezeigt werden von den Leuten, die überrott gegangen sind. Was für eine geniale Idee ist das denn bitte? Aber wie fändest du das eine Bestrafung? Du willst halt nicht, dass alle deine Familie, deine Freunde, deine Verwandte, alle sehen bei der Kreuzung. Nicht der Hut. Den Hut hat er auch. Du willst nicht, dass die sehen, dass du überr gegangen bist. Ja. Ich glaube, das ist in China noch ein grösseres Ding, über Rot gehen an sich, aber ich finde das schon einfach eine gute Idee, diese Idee, das nach außen zu tragen, dass es nicht, wenn du nur alleine bestraft wirst und dann dir freigestellt ist, ob du Leuten erzählst oder nicht, ob du dann in die Kühe geschnappt wurdest und dass man das einfach öffentlich macht. Ich finde das interessant. Ich glaube, das kann nach hinten losgehen, oder? Ja, natürlich. Also wenn du da so ein Influencer bist oder so und dann denkst du einfach, okay, so krieg ich mein Gesicht nach draußen, ist schon schwierig. Ich bin tatsächlich immer bei roten Ampeln immer in so einem moralischen Konflikt, da sind wir wieder, moralischer Konflikt. Ja, ist der rote Fahrrad. Ich musste letztens super schnell zum Bahnhof rennen und es war rote Ampel, nichts war da, mir gegenüber, wirklich eine Mutter mit einem achtjährigen Mädchen in der Hand. Und die Mutter guckt so, nichts ist da, ich gucke so, nichts ist da, und die Mutter gibt mir diesen Blick des, don't even try, denk gar nicht dran. Und ich war wirklich so, schau aufs Handy, so, na, ich hab's eilig, da kann man Ausnahmen machen. Und die Mutter nur so, Oh, dich. Nö, nö, nö, nö. Hat sie auch gesagt, ficken Sie sich. Und dieses Mädchen auch mit so grossen Augen, noch bin ich unbedarft, noch bin ich perfekt, willst du mich zerstören, willst du dieser eine Einfluss sein, der mich auf die falsche Bahn bringt, einfach einmal rund im Ohr und Heroin direkt. Und ich war ... und ich hab's nicht übers Herz gebracht. Ich hab's nicht übers Herz gebracht. Ich suche auch immer dann an dieser Situation nach etwas, was mir gibt, dass ihre Erziehung auch nicht perfekt ist. Ach so, ja, ja, klar. Dass man dann irgendwas sieht, dass sie sie zu doll an der Hand hält oder so, wo man sagt, na ja, na ja, ich gehe vielleicht über Rot, aber sie haben das Kind so doll geschoben, durch die Strasse geschoben, hinter sich hergezogen. Man findet dann offen nichts. Aber es ist schwierig. Das Problem ist nur, ich entscheide mich dann irgendwann, weil die Bahn anbietig kommt, über Rot zu gehen, und in dem Moment wird es grün. Das heißt, ich ging die ganze Zeit durch diesen Prozess, hatte keine Lust und sie sieht auch, ich wäre gegangen. Meine Reaktionszeit war zu schnell. Das heißt, du machst nichts falsch, hast aber trotzdem den ganzen Hass der Leute auf dich gerichtet, wenn du in dem Moment genau losgehst, wenn es grün wird, weil du dich Entscheidung getroffen hast, du gehst jetzt los noch, um die Bahn zu bekommen und genau dann bist du grün. Vor allem, wenn du der Erste bist, ziehen alle anderen nach, das ist wirklich so eine Kettenreaktion, wie so eine große Sanduhr. Wenn da einer loslegt, dann stürmen alle nach. Ja, das Kind auch und dann kommt der Lkw. Ja, ja, alle tot. Alle, alle tot. Und dann ist was passiert, was dann passiert? Wegen dir sind dann alle. Ja, das ist das Problem. Aber kriegst du dafür eine Strafe? Vielleicht? Ja. Weiss es nicht genau. Ziemlich sicher. Ich bin kein Anwalt. Dein Bild hängt gross mit so einem Photoshop, so einem Schnurrbart.
Und so Fliegen über deinen Kopf und du so verdammt noch mal, jetzt haben sie mich erwischt. Und daneben steht so ein Prominenter, den alle mögen, der macht so. Ja, was, Thomas Müller mag mich nicht? War da gerade Florentin Will? Auf der Ampel und Thomas Müller, die neben ihm sagt ...
Das ist eine komische Kampagne neuerdings, ich gehe nicht mehr über Rot. Einfach so Fäden, einfach so off, öffentliche Beefs werden so ausgetragen, einfach nur über so die Nase zuhalten und Daumen runter. Ich fand aber das eine spannende Idee, dieses Konzept, Leute bestraften mit etwas, was dann der Allgemeinheit zuwürdig gemacht wird. Und ich fand es interessant, den Gedanken, dass man vielleicht außen am Auto Dinge anbringt, wenn innen was falsch läuft, zum Beispiel. Aha, okay. Du bist nicht angeschnallt, aber draußen geht die Lampe an, wenn du nicht angeschnallt bist. Ja. Dass alle um dich herumsehen, ha, der ist nicht angeschnallt. Oder du hast dann außen so dieses Piep-Geräusch, so bim, bim, außen hin. Ja, ja, genau. Ich glaube, es wird aber auch viel helfen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, trotzdem würden sich die meisten anschnallen, weil sie keine Lust haben, dass draußen dieses nervige Geräusch angeht, weil alle von draußen reingucken und sagen, du bist bescheuert. Ich finde das eine gute Idee. Ich habe tatsächlich diese Woche das erste Mal, war ich grob im Auto. Bitte? Ich war rüde im Auto, ich war grob, ich war grob im Auto und zwar in dieser furchtbare Situation, wenn an einer Ampel, wo du fahren darfst als Autofahrer, da kommt ein Fussgänger ganz schnell angelaufen und du weisst nicht, ob er abbremst oder nicht und du musst aber abbremsen, weil du kannst nicht vorhersehen, ob er noch abbremsen will oder nicht und ich bremse ab, der sieht, dass ich abbremse, geht rüber und dann habe ich dem, dann habe ich dem den Mittelfinger gezeigt. Was? Und ich habe das wirklich noch nie in meinem Leben gemacht und ich habe es gemacht. Warst du sauer im Gesicht? Ich war sauer im Gesicht, ich war aber so nicht sauer genug im Gesicht, ich dachte mir so, kurz mal checken, dein Gesicht ist nicht sauer genug, können dir die Hände noch helfen? Können dir, gibt es da irgendwie, kann kurz jemand helfen? Ganz kurz, es war eine normale Strasse. Normale Strasse, ich hatte grün, er kam angelaufen, so mit diesem Fuck, hält er an oder nicht, ich muss stehen bleiben, weil sonst, weiss ich nicht, fahre ich ihn um, bleib stehen, er guckt und läuft rüber. Keine so schlimm, aber …
Doch, es ist schlimm, ich finde das furchtbar. So, und ich bin ein sehr, sehr friedliebender Autofahrer. Ich richte den Hass immer, so wie das gesunde Menschen machen, auf sich selbst, immer Hass auf sich selbst. Bist du ein sehr trauriger Autofahrer? Immer Hass in den Spiegel rein, immer Hass in den Spiegel rein, der kann und erhält das aus. Und da war dieser Typ, und dann habe ich dem den Mittelfinger gezeigt und er ist sofort bereut, wirklich, es war sofort bereut und er guckt mich noch so an und ich so, wirklich so, wirklich so, wirklich so, wirklich so, dann ist das Ding, das musst du üben, ja, ja, ich weiß, und es war so eine, es war so eine Geste für, na du weißt doch, wie menschliche Emotionen sind, sorry, wirklich so, na du weißt doch, wie das ist, manchmal regt man sich aus, es ist zu viel für eine Geste. Jetzt geh, jetzt geh. Es war zu viel für eine Geste und ich weisse, es tut mir echt leid, also falls du da draußen gerade zuhörst und du von einem wild und merklichen Geste kenne. Es tut dir so sehr leid, dass du dir das über öffentlich nach ihm suchst? Ja, es tut mir leid, es tut mir wirklich leid, so sollte man nicht sein. Aber warum, das verletzt ihn ja jetzt auch nicht. Ja, doch. Ich will den Tag nicht ruinieren, weil dir jemand mit Mittelfinger gezahlt hat. Es ist einer der schlimmsten Finger schon. Es ist einer unter den Top drei schlimmsten Finger. Top elf Finger. Das würde ich auch sagen, das würde ich sofort unterschreiben. Aber das ist interessant, dass das die Situation ist, die dich auf die Palme bringt. Ja, das bringt mich auf die Palme. Das Ding ist, ich erklär's dir. Mich bringt vor allem Dinge auf die Palme, wo Menschen unbewusst scheiße sind. Wenn jemand ein Arschloch ist und sich einfach reindrängelt und jeder sieht, das ist ein Arschloch, dann ist es so mit einer gewissen, ja, den kann ich respektieren. So, der ist ein selbstbewusstes Arschloch, der weiss auch, dass es scheisse ist, was er tut, dem ist es halt nur scheissegal.
So, da kann man auch nichts machen, weil wenn man dem jetzt den Finger zeigt, der denkt sich, ja, ich weiss, dass ich ein Arschloch bin, deswegen mache ich ja das. Danke. So, ja, na, da haben wir es doch, wunderbar. So, dem ist es egal, der macht das schon seit Jahren, der weiss, wie es geht, ein Arschloch zu sein, der lebt das. Aber was ich nicht mag, wenn Leute nicht wissen, dass sie gerade mega stören oder jemanden mega in Bedrängnis bringen, wie so wenn Fahrradfahrer super schnell an eine Kreuzung anfahren und in der letzten Sekunde halten und du als Autofahrer immer nicht weißt, bremst der noch, bremst der noch, muss ich bremsen, bremst der noch und in der letzten Sekunde und dem ist gar nicht bewusst, dass ich gerade wütend irgendwie in mein Daido-Album reinbrülle, weil ich einfach stocksauer bin gerade.
Und das weisst er nicht. Um dem würde ich dann gerne mal so ein Fenster unterscheiden und sagen,
ja, wissen Sie was, mein Freund, Sie haben mir da gerade einen Schrecken eingejagt, gerade mit ihrem Karacho da. Sie pesen hier durch die Stadt. Und dann beschämt das Fenster wieder hoch machen, langsam. Das beschlagene Fenster hoch war.
Und der Wunderbaum wackelt.
Ja, aber kannst du es nachvollziehen, solche Leute nerven mich mehr, weil die gar nicht wissen, dass sie Arschlöcher sind. Sondern so, vvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvv Nee, nee, nee. Nee, komm. Nee, vor allem wichtig ist vor allem, dass man erst die Zentralverregelung anmacht. Ja. Und bei sowas habe ich immer Angst, weil gerade Fussgänger, ich bin sehr fies gegenüber anderen Autofahrern,
weil ich weiß, oh, da müssen viele Dinge passieren, bis sie jetzt zu mir reinkommen. So, ich bin in meinem kleinen Metallkäfig, fuck you, Welt, so, und ich fahre rum, ne, ich bin schnell, der fährt, das Ries.
Eine Hand an der Hupe die ganze Zeit. Ja, natürlich, so, durch Köln kann ich auch nur so fahren, mit der linken Hand an der Hupe auf jeden Fall. Und das ist nicht schlimm, weil da müssen viele Dinge passieren, bis er zu mir rüberkommt. Aber wenn du den Fußgänger hast, bin ich super vorsichtig, ich habe Angst vor Fußgängern. Ja. Weil die können sofort reinkommen, deswegen erst Zentralverlegerung, danach der Mittelfänger. Mir ist es schon oft passiert, dass ich jemanden angeschrien habe und dann merkst du, dass er dich hört. Richtig, und dann erst gemerkt, fuck er. Ja, weil das ist so dünnes Glas. Ja, das ist vor allem, stellst alle meine Musical-Performances im Auto in Frage, weil ich immer selbstbewusst war und zum einen dachte, mich kann niemand sehen, obwohl ich in einem Glaskäfig bin. Ja! Und dachte, mich kann niemand hören, obwohl ich in einem Glaskäfig bin. Man hört Menschen.
Es stimmt, Autofahren ist ein bisschen wie Kino. So, du guckst durch eine Leinwand die Welt an und erst mal fühlt man sich distanziert und denkt sich, man kann machen, was man will. Aber diese Welt existiert. Ja, das ist wie wenn du so einen Horrorfilm schaust und sagst so, nein, geht nicht in den Keller und die Figur im Film so, ja okay, dann halt nicht. Fakt dann halt nicht, Mann. Okay, dann Ich spann dich mal ein bisschen.
Ich rufe die Polizei an, okay, so der Film ist vorbei.
Der Film ist vorbei.
Und man denkt sich so, nein, oh nein, ich habe den Film ruhig. Und so ist das, wenn ich im Auto schreie und dann die Person nimmt mir so, aber auch so völlig, weil die hört es ja so 20 Dezibel leiser, so, du brüllst dir die Seele aus, bleib und bei der Person kommt, brr brr brr brr brr. Und ihr so, okay, hallo? Es kommt einfach nicht gut an. Ja, ja, das stimmt schon auch. Ich bin neulich, da habe ich sehr aufgeregt, und vor allem, ich bin der schlimmste Autofahrer. Ich hasse mich auch selber dafür, aber ich bin dann sehr emotional. Wenn mir jemand dann zum Beispiel mich schneidet oder sowas, dann gebe ich Gas, um neben dem zu fahren auf die Autobahn und ihn anzugucken. Das ist immer die grösste Befriedigung, ist immer heraus, ich weiss nicht, ich weiss nicht, mit beiden Händen gestikuliert, Lenkrad vergesse ich dann völlig. Kurz aufstehen, auf dem Beifahrersitz klettern, hallo. Und dann macht der Autofahrer zu mir, beide fahren aneinander rein. Nein, aber das Ding ist, ich will halt irgendwie, es ist beschafft, so eine Befriedigung herauszufinden, wer diesen ShitmMove gemacht hat. Und meistens, ich weiß nicht, was ich erwarte dann, aber ich bin immer, ich denke immer, ja, da habe ich mir gedacht, dass du das bist. Genau, aber jetzt... Es geht nicht auf Geschlechter, es geht nicht auf Alter, es ist nichts, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das tut mir leid. I call Bullshit. Ich sage auch nicht jetzt genau, Kategorisierung von Menschen, aber jeder hat eine Erwartung. Bei schlechtem Autofahren. Ja, jeder hat eine Erwartung. Alte Asiatinnen. Ja, aber im Ernst. Und jedes Mal, wenn du eine siehst, denkst du, na wusste ich es doch. Es ist einfach so, es ist in Menschen drin. Aber man hört ja meine rassistischen Slurs nicht im Auto, inzwischen für zwei Millimeter
Glassitze. Jeder Mensch weiss selber, wie rassistisch er oder sie ist. Aber jeder weiss,
dass man das noch nicht zeigen darf. Das Schlimmste ist nur, man fährt dann neben
denen und man nach diesem wütenden Ausdruck in der Hoffnung, dass er da Mittelfinger zeigt oder
so den macht, aber da war da so ein älterer Mann, der gesagt hat, so sorry,
und ich war so, es nimmt dir sofort jeglichen Wind aus den Segeln und du bist sofort so, naja, komm, alles gut. Bei mir war die Situation, dass man dann so an der Ampel anfährt und nebeneinander steht und man noch in der Wut ist und so einfach gestikuliert oder einfach nur so kurz, diese Gesten sind nicht für, nicht für eine Ampelschaltung gedacht, diese Gesten sind kurze, Kur das sind nicht, und dann steht man dann müde lang nebeneinander und irgendwann gehen dann die Gesten aus. Und der andere auch nur so. Und dann geht es nicht weiter. So, dann geht es einfach nicht weiter. Und dann wird man sich wieder Daido unter dem Lenkrad. Und dann tut man so, als wäre es nicht geschehen, einfach so. Das ist so ein bisschen so, wenn ich mich manchmal so auf Pick-up-Artists-Seiten rumtreibe, aus reiem Interesse, also als reine Recherche, für mein neues... Ach gut, das Abschwächen willst du mit aus reiner Interesse. Ja, genau das war unser aller Problem. Nee, einfach weil ich es geil finde. Ja, ich bin auf Pornoseornoseiten einfach weil es mich interessiert. Ja, ja. Nicht aus anderen Gründen. Und da haben wir auch so diese klassischen Anmachsprüche, diese ganz schlechten, die glaube ich auch noch nie gesagt wurden in der Welt, halt einfach so diese ganzen, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, deine Uhr geht feil, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, du hast, deine Uhr geht falsch. Ich bin schon ein bisschen scharf auf dich im Ernst. Ja, das ist so, deine Uhr geht falsch, warum, ich habe keine Unterwäsche an, okay. Du hast Narben im Gesicht, warum, bist du vom Himmel gefallen, ich habe Narben, aber man kann es so halb, hat was auch im Kopf. Aber da denke ich mir auch immer so, egal wie gut der Spruch ist, es lässt danach erst mal so ein gewisses Vakuum entstehen. Ja. Denn so ein bisschen, du bist, Engel, du bist vom Himmel gefallen. Und was machst du beruflich? Einfach so, wie geht's dann weiter? Das ist dann erstmal so ein, okay, jetzt, wie, weiß man nicht genau. Ich weiß nicht genau. Einfach so ein Icebreaker und dann ist man auf Base. Ja, aber wohin mit dem Eis? Dann hast du das gebrochene Eis, aber wohin? So. Ja, vor allem unterm Eis, will man das Eis überhaupt brechen? Das ist keine gute Metapher. Man will nicht, dass das Eis bricht. Überhaupt nicht. Danach kaltes, tödliches Wasser, das kommt nach Eis. Man sagt ja, es ist dünnes Eis, also das Eis soll nicht brechen. Lass das Eis, wie es ist, verdammt noch mal, denk an die Eisbären. Ich bin Eisbilder, mehr Eis zwischen uns. Ja, weniger Eisbrecher, mehr Schlittschuh fahren. Das geht, manche verstehen, finden das romantisch. So heißt das dein Pick-up-Arts-Buch. Ja, von mir aus. Weniger Eisbrecher, mehr Schlittschuh fahren. Spiegel-Bestseller. Ja, wir haben sich heute hier eingeladen, um ein bisschen über Ihr Buch zu sprechen. Sorry. Was, wollten wir schon mal sagen? Entschuldigung, ich hätte das. Sie haben dieses Pick-up-artes-Buch geschrieben. Wie kam es dazu? Ja, ich dachte mir, viele romantische Bücher sind ja sehr platt, ne, also so dann irgendwie Twilight oder Twilight 2 oder Twilight 3 oder jetzt… Twilight 4? Zum Beispiel, ein gutes Beispiel, sind ja sehr platt irgendwie, da gibt es dann so, oh, ich liebe dich so sehr, Edward, Bella, das ist dann immer so ein Ding. Ich dachte mir, meine romantischen Bücher sollen so Liebe auf den zweiten Blick. Man kennt ja Liebe auf den ersten Blick irgendwie, aber was kommt danach? Deswegen war meine Idee, warum nicht Liebe auf den zweiten Blick? So Liebesgedichte, Sprüche, die man liest und erst mal denkt so, was, die erst mal so reifen müssen. Liebe muss reifen. Liebe ist so ein bisschen wie ein Ferrero-Küsschen auf der Fensterbank. Es wird immer schlechter, schmilzt und man sollte es dringend wegwerfen. Ja, oder man muss es erst vergessen, um es wiederzufinden.
Und dann ist es aber...
Und dann findet man es wieder.
Und es ist geschmolzen, schlechter, und man sollte es dann wegwerfen.
Na, sehen Sie.
Also es ist, wie gesagt, für jeden...
Es ist unterschiedlich.
Romantik ist ja auch für jeden anders. So ein bisschen. Ich finde, jedes Liebespaar spricht seine eigene Sprache. Die können andere ja gar nicht verstehen. Indisch. Gut. Indisch. Ja, nein, ich meine jetzt im Sinne von, für andere ist das ja albern von außen. Indisch. Wie meinen Sie das? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, es da in Ihrem Buch irgendwelche Tipps, die ich mitnehmen kann? Ja, ja. Ist die Frau in einer akuten Notsituation? Das heißt kein Nein. Das ist kein Nein. Nee, sie ist nicht in einer akuten Notsituation. Scheisse. Gut, was wäre denn, wenn sie in einer akuten Notsituation gewesen wäre? Ja, ähm. Es ist ein sehr spezifisches Buch offensichtlich. Ja, ja, wie gesagt, es ist halt so ein, ähm ... Sind Sie in einer Beziehung eigentlich?
Sie gehen auf sie zu, sagen wir jetzt mal, egal welche Situation, und dann sagen Sie,
im Casino der Liebe setze ich mein ganzes Geld auf schwarz. Sehen Sie, sehen Sie, manchmal ist es so leicht, manchmal ist es so leicht, ja, haben Sie vielleicht, Können Sie mir vielleicht ein Handy noch mal geben oder so?
Null. Ja, 015 und den Rest kriegen Sie schon raus. Kein Problem. Das ist zum Beispiel auch ein guter Trick, man gibt die Handynummer, aber lässt die letzte Zahl weg. Und dann merkt man, wie ernst die Person meint. Wie ernst die Person meint. Weil sie will ja dann neun verschiedene … Richtig, du musst erst bald neun extrem unangenehme Gespräche führen, wovor du bei mir landest. Wenn sie es ernster meinen, lassen die die letzten vier Zahlen weg. Sie können das beliebig ausweiten. Vier Fakultät wäre dann die... Ja, ja, ja. Die Exponentialfunktion der Liebe strebt gegen unendlich. Gut, das wird sehr nischig jetzt. Ich habe, wie gesagt, für alle möglichen Berufsstände verschiedene Sachen, für Jahrmarkt zum Beispiel, im Spiegelkabinett der Liebe. Habe ich einen dicken Bauch? Verdammt, das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist nicht schlecht. Wegen der ganzen Schmetterlinge. Im Spiegelkabinett der Liebe sehe ich unendlich mal mich. Wie gesagt, Liebe auf den zweiten Blick, auf den zweiten Blick. Es darf nicht zu leicht sein. Liebe zwischen den Zeilen. Ja, Liebe zwischen den Zähnen, so ein bisschen. Das ist so ein bisschen, bisschen, ja. Liebe ist, wenn man sich gegenseitig den Spinat aus den Zähnen rauspult. Verstehen Sie, wie ich meine? Nee, ich finde das ganz toll. Was, wie lange dauert die Sendung? Was ist das? Wir haben noch ganz viel Zeit. Ach so, ja. Haben Sie denn noch mal vor, noch mal ein Buch zu schreiben oder sind Sie gerade eigentlich in der Beziehung? Es ist kompliziert, sage ich mal so. Meine aktuelle Freundin ist an ein Vorabexemplar des Buchs gekommen. Gestorben, achso. Achso, nee, nee, nee. Ihre Tochter ist leider gestorben, weil jemand bei Rot über die Ampel gelaufen ist, Leider überfahren hat. Das ist das Schlimmste. Schade. Ich werde für so Fernseher die dann die Gesichter zeigen. Liebe ist wie ein Kindersag. Im besten Fall kauft man nur einen. Und das war der Punkt, an dem sie dann nicht mehr so... An dem die Sendung abgebrochen wird. An dem dann diese Störung, kennt man ja, wie man mit Unwetter zu sprechen war. Komisch, dass an solchen Stellen immer dann das Sat-1-Unwetter-Zeichen kommt. Das Unwetter der Liebe. Es ist zu leicht, es ist fast zu leicht. Es ist fast zu leicht. Aber hast du mal jemals so etwas versucht bei einer Frau? Hast du jemals so versucht? So ein Spruch? Ja, so ein Anmachspruch. Ne, ich habe einmal einen Liebesbrief geschrieben. Ich auch als Kind tatsächlich. Na ja, komm, ihr kennt den Brief nicht, okay? Awww. Und zwar war das… Aber es war so ein mitleidiges Awww, es war nicht mehr süss, es war schon, sorry, dass es nicht geklappt hat. Es war ein… Ich hatte die Geschichte noch nicht mal erzählt. Es war ein Liebesbrief, Schrägstrich Weihnachtsges so ein bisschen die Todeskombo auch genannt wird in Fachkreisen. Was war das Geschenk? Gute Frage. Fight Club. Der Film Fight Club war das Geschenk auf DVD. Auf DVD. Und der Brief war rückblickend zu lang. Ich habe eigentlich alles Wichtige schon in den ersten vier Zeilen gesagt, so die Klassiker wie, man spricht nicht über den Fight Club. Ja, genau. Ja, genau. Ich denke nochmal eins. Ja, es ist immer schwer so, wie macht man dann weiter, nachdem man alles gesagt hat, was man sagen will, und dann driftet man so ein bisschen ins Triviale ab, aber hat auch nicht gut funktioniert, keine Antwort bekommen.
Bis heute.
Bis heute. Man weiss auch nicht genau, soll man dann die Adresse draufschreiben, wie geht das Rückumschlag, ist das ein bisschen zu needy, wenn man einen frankierten Rückumschlag.
Einschreiben, mit Einschreiben, sie muss unterschreiben, wenn sie bekommen hat, dann kann ich so irgendwann hingehen so, äh, ich weiß, dass du den Brief bekommen hast. Warum haben wir keine Antwort? Ich habe sogar versichert. Ja, es ist schwierig, vor allem das war diese, so in jungen Jahren, wo man bei seinen Eltern wohnt, wo halt auch super unangenehm ist, dann sich zu diesem Briefkasten hinzuschleichen, weil man dann auch nicht genau, dann arbeitet die Mutter im Garten und man denkt sich so, okay, du hast jetzt diesen Brief-in Druckerpapier eingepackte Feilklapp-DVD, weil ich kein Geschenkpapier habe. Was ist angemessenes Geschenkpapier? Und dann so steigt man so vorbei und wirft ein Briefkast. Das wäre halt geil, wenn du diese, ich habe mich mal gefragt, ich als als Kind habe ich Pfeil und Bogen gekauft, du hast es gemacht, finde ich deutlich cooler, so, du hast die echte Pfeile, die man töten können gebaut, ich hätte immer die mit diesen Guminoppen vor und dran, die kurz an der Scheibe hängen bleiben, kurz, die wären geil für so Liebesbrief, die wären perfekt, vor allem die Fester Scheibe, Mutter arbeitet im Garten und du stehst irgendwie zehn Kilometer entfernt und ballerst den an die Scheibe. Aber das ist die klassische Mutter. Ja genau, das ist die klassische Verwechslungskomödie. Und dann bist du mit der Mutter zusammen und sie so, what the? Genau. Und die Mutter verliebt sich dann automatisch in dich und denkt, what the fuck? Man weiss es nicht. Komische Geschichte. Es ist eine merkwürdige Geschichte. Das Eins-Eins-Film-Film. Komisch. Der Wind-Film, wo alles durch Wind erklärt wird. Ach komisch, dass man das bei... Der zwei durch Wind abgelämmt. Alle haben dann irgendwie so Montagskino und so und Sann-Eins hat sich für Film-Film entschieden. Ey, aber brillant. Was ist da denn los? Sann-Eins-Film-Film. Es ist brillant. Es stellt mir jetzt auf, wie dusselig der Name ist. Sann-Eins-Film. Film-Qu Filmquadrat, man könnte es wegkürzen eigentlich. Es stimmt schon. Aber wie gesagt, 2020 ist das Jahr der Wiederholungen, der Reime, der 2020 ist auch wie ein Filmfilm eigentlich so, man macht es einfach doppelt. 2020, 20 auf 2. Das Jahrzehnt ist vorbei, ist dir das klar eigentlich? Ja, jetzt beginnen die Willen Zwanziger, oder? Ja, aber jetzt ist das Problem, jetzt kommen wir bald in die Zwanziger, kommen die Dreissiger, so man kommt halt wieder in die Zahlen, die schon besetzt sind. Das ist halt problematisch. Es ist nervig, aber wo wir gerade beim Thema Liebe und Flirten waren, vielleicht haben es manche von euch mitbekommen, es gibt eine, ich sage mal, ein Klassiker der Podcast-Ufo-Geschichte, der eine meiner Avancen dokumentiert, gerichtet auf eine junge Dame, die ich versucht habe, gekonnt zu hofieren, im Backstage-Bereich, vielleicht kennen manche von euch diese Geschichte, wie ich versucht habe, vor ihr den Wohltäter zu geben und ihr Bullshit erzählt habe. Ich habe gesagt, ich würde mich um Hunde kümmern, kam aus dieser Lügengeschichte nicht mehr raus. Fünf Jahre lang hielt dieses Geheimnis, bis sie jetzt diese Geschichte gefunden hat. Super spät, muss man sagen. Super spät und in ihrem Podcast besprochen hat, mich eingeladen hat in ihrem Podcast. Und ich war letzte Woche bei Joyce Ilk in ihrem Podcast und wir haben diese gesamte Geschichte geklärt. Es war nicht extrem unangenehm, es war okay unangenehm. So ein leichtes Kribbeln, wie so ein Horrorfilm und sich denkt, ich bin nicht wirklich in Lebensgefahr, aber gern wäre ich da auch nicht. Das Einzige, was ich mitbekomme davon, ist, dass ich sie damals beleidigt hätte, weil sie es nicht mehr weiss. Du kommst schlimmer weg als ich. Dass sie mich in allen Gesprächen, in unserem Gespräch damals, wo die Geschichte erzählt hast, wo ich nur in der letzten Reihe sitze und die ganze Zeit rufe, die ist dumm. Und dann kam ich... Du hattest damals eine andere Rolle im Podcast. Ja, weirde Rolle. Gonsten habe ich mich ein bisschen verändert. Bei eurem Gespräch war ich gar nicht erst eingeladen, und dann habe ich immer nur so Tweets bekommen die ganze Zeit, so, dass sie mich auch die ganze Zeit fertig gemacht hätte jetzt, weil sie es in dem Podcast angehört hat, wo dann dieser Grinsebube im Hintergrund in der letzten Reihe sitzt und die ganze Zeit ruft, dass sie... Oh Mann, ich muss mich schon wieder entschuldigen nächste Woche, wenn du jetzt hier wieder vom Stapel lässt. Okay, aber was ist denn jetzt da passiert? Das ist Konfrontation. Es war eine sehr unangenehme Situation, ich habe versucht, sie zu beeindrucken mit meinem unendlichen Humor, indem ich ihr damals eine Lügengeschichte aufgetischt habe. Ich wusste, sie interessiert sich sehr für Hunde und deswegen habe ich erzählt, ja, ich habe auch einen verlassenen Hund bei mir aufgenommen und ich kümmere mich ja sehr total um Kinder und so und sie hat das aber sehr ernst genommen und ich kam aus der Geschichte nicht mehr raus und jetzt ist das aber alles aufgeklärt worden und na ja, ich habe, sage ich mal, nicht allzu viel... Ihr seid nicht mehr zusammen, um es kurz zu machen. Ja, ich habe alles auf Schwarz gesetzt und verloren. Aber ich war dann und habe versucht, das mit ihr so ein bisschen aufzuklären. Es ist ein sehr interessantes Gespräch geworden, sie war auch super nett und super verständnisvoll, aber ich konnte es natürlich nicht lassen, mal wieder denselben, exakt selben Fehler zu machen, um es kurz zu machen. Und zwar haben wir, weil dann war so dieses, ha ha ha, ich habe dich angelogen, wie wohltätig ich bin und dann halt so eine Stunde in einem Podcast oder so erzähle ich, dann war so, ja ja, war auch irgendwie schwierig dann damals, wir haben dann tatsächlich auch zusammen im selben Haus gewohnt, also nicht in der selben Wohnung, sondern im selben Haus.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, war eine schwere Zeit für mich, hat er im dritten Stock gewohnt und ich hatte ja damals diesen Hund adoptiert, ne, dem wurden ja erst die Vorderbeine und dann die Hinterbeine auch noch amputiert. Ach, ich muss mich so. Dann musste ich den jeden Tag die Treppe hochtragen und es war eine schwere Zeit, aber es war es total wert.
Sie schaut mich an mit eiserner Miene und meint so, ja, wir hatten tatsächlich mal einen Hund, den wir die Treppe hochtragen mussten, weil er nicht mehr laufen konnte. Und ich bin exakt, in exakt dieselbe Falle nochmal reingelaufen wie damals vor fünf Jahren. Ich habe wieder einen Gag gemacht über einen bedürftigen Hund und bin wieder reingelaufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine unendliche Geschichte ist, dass ich jetzt jede Woche in Ihrem Podcast zu Gast sein muss. Aber wie blöd muss sie denn sein, dass jetzt wird es wieder eine Geschichte. Nein, ich durchbreche den Kreis, indem ich das nicht kommentiere. Kann sich ja jeder selbst schon ein Bild machen, wie man das findet, dass sie dann so eine Geschichte anfängt. Aber von allen Geschichten, allem, was einem Hund passieren kann, nämlich genau exakt das, was ihrem Hund tatsächlich passiert ist. Er ist gefallen aus dem dritten Stock? Nee, ich weiß nicht genau. Vor allem diese Katze, wer würde sich einfach normal landen? Ich glaube, ihm ist ein wütender Autofahrer über die Pfoten gefahren, einfach in einem Smartcar to go, man weiss nicht genau, wer das war. Aber es war eine tragische... Aber das ist interessant, jetzt langsam kommen wir in dieses Zeitalter, in das Jahrzehnt, wo sich so Podcast-UFO-Geschichten auflösen. So, die Stollenleins nähern sich Akt drei zu. Vor allem, das war ja damals eine ganz andere Situation, wir hatten ja damals ja irgendwie zehn Hörer oder so, und man hat solche Sachen erzählt mit dem absoluten Wissen, das wird nie jemand mitbekommen. Man hat kein Blatt vor den Mund genommen. Überhaupt nicht, und deswegen glaube ich, wird da noch viel ausgegraben werden, und ich habe ja auch erzählt von unserem Keep It Das Podcast UFO, Keep It Joyce Ilk, Desaster. Wow, jetzt haben wir bald einen riesen Urheberrechtsstreit noch einmal. Ja, ja, alles ist raus, es war, also es ist gut, manchmal auch so Sachen auf dem Deckel drauf zu machen, ne, das ist so, ja eigentlich so, so genau so, wie wenn man damals so einen Liebesbrief schreibt, einfach nochmal, einfach nochmal antworten, zehn Jahre später. Also ich, ich motiviere alle, die hier zuhören, falls ihr unbeantwortete Liebesbriefe in eurer Schublade habt, einfach mal antworten. Einfach mal sagen, ist angekommen, jo, smiley. Das ist doch ein super Auftrag für die nächste Woche. Ja. Für die nächste Woche ist euer Auftrag, bringt mal die offenen Storylines eures Lebens, die noch so in Akt zwei rumplätschern, die ihr liegen lassen habt, bringt die mal zu Ende. Bringt Geschichten full circle. Das ist unser Auftrag. So Sachen, die ihr schon immer mal Leuten sagen wollt, es gibt bestimmt irgendeine Joyce-Ill-Geschichte bei euch zu Hause, die ihr auch noch ewig mit euch rumtragt, löst sie auf. Aber nacheinander, nicht alles gleichzeitig bei Abladen. Die arme Joyce kriegt ansonsten einfach 20.000 Mails. Ich habe dir auch schon mal Scheiße erzählt, nur dass ihr geglaubt. Alright, vielen, vielen Dank, Stuttgart, ihr wart ein ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz fantastisches Publikum. Das erste Publikum der dritten Tour. Grossartig. Einen grossen Applaus für euch erstmal. Woo! Für euch. Für euch. Für euch, ihr wart toll. Dankeschön. Für euch, ihr wart toll. Vielen Dank auch nochmal, wo man euch so sieht, vielen Dank an die tollen Beiträge, die ihr uns liefert aus Afrika. Vielen Dank für die ganzen Intros, die ihr auch heute immer gehört habt, in voller Glorie. Es war fantastisch. Unfassbar. Vielen, vielen Dank. Und falls ihr noch Bock habt, wir sind gleich noch am Mördstand. Und sagen Hallo, reden kurz mit jedem, aber wir haben noch ein Fenster von zehn Minuten mit jedem, sodass es nicht zu spät wird. Falls ihr Hallo sagen wollt, kommt gerne ans Ansonsten vielen, vielen Dank fürs Kommen, haut rein, macht's gut.
Morgen schön am Stuttgart!
Macht's gut.
Hau rein!